[Musique]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
tuesday.com/aventure tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent aussi
bien sur le site internet que sur nos
applications iOS et Android pour vivre
votre passion comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
que vous pouvez pimenter vos parties en
ligne et vous analyser avec des emojis
il vous suffit de cliquer sur l'icône
emoji puis de sélectionner votre emoji
et de cliquer avec le bouton gauche de
la souris sur l'échiquier vous pouvez
choisir parmi une multitude de notations
de coûts d'animation d'émoticônes et
même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs des émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts et les animations spéciales
restent sur l'échiquier jusqu'à ce
qu'elles soient effacées pour ce faire
il suffit de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'emoji ou de
cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
vous les streamer des échecs comme vous
créateurs préférés tels que blindstream
Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamers en direct votre
profites.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties offert utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
demi-finale des perdants avec aussi avec
ici une grande demi-finale c'est lasalik
contre
ici environ 5 10 minutes donc les
caméras des joueurs sont là mais les
joueurs sont pas devant la caméra qui
vient d'arriver alors pour faire un
petit résumé rapide de de ce qui se
passe dans ce tournoi regardez bien ici
vous avez le bracket du tournoi on a ici
du coup Magnus Carlson qui est qui est
en finale de l'événement vous voyez la
grande finale ici et en dessous dans le
paquet déperdant et ben c'est tous les
joueurs qui ont déjà perdu une fois dans
le moi donc on a ici en demi-finale on a
là David qui a commencé par jouer contre
carwana vous voyez il a perdu contre
Carolina lors du premier tour en quart
de finale des gagnants et ensuite il a
enchaîné la victoire contre Tabata Bay
de 1 et là contre so ouest les grandes
surprises de 1 et il se retrouve en
demi-finale contre ab12 à torov dans un
côté abdosotarov et ben il a également
perdu le premier tour en quart de finale
contre fille rouge à 3-0 et en ce qui
s'est réveillé il a gagné 1 et demi
contre elianov et de 1 contre Kawana
donc car voilà c'est aussi pas une mince
affaire et maintenant et ben il est en
demi-finale des perdant contre laservic
ton gros match le vainqueur de ce match
sera opposé à firouzja donc qu'il attend
de pied ferme elle lirezakia qui avait
fait un super start en battant Abdou 3-0
dans le premier set enfin dans le
premier quart de finale puis sa deux et
demi un demi en demi-finale pour hier
perdre
il était franchement assez incroyable
franchement
injouable quand il est dans cette forme
là et donc à perdu hier et va devoir
j'imagine envie de se refaire dans cette
finale des loosers qui sera opposé
contre vainqueur de demi-finale ici et
le vainqueur de la finale des perdants
sera opposé à Marius Carlsen demain donc
ce joueur qui sera en finale opposé à
carcène pour à l'obligation de le battre
deux fois alors deux fois parce que vous
savez que dans cet événement pour être
éliminé il faut perdre deux matchs et
pour l'instant Carlson il l'a perdu 0
match c'est-à-dire qu'il a encore une
vie c'est-à-dire que si par exemple à
l'ireza arrivé en finale 345 et ben si
cantine gagne le premier match et ben
c'est terminé parce qu'il y a du raisin
aura perdu c'est de match un match
contrecarte saine en finale des gagnants
et dans la grande finale aussi alors que
si Ali resa un pâté Carlsen dans la
grande finale et ben Garden aurait une
deuxième chance parce que vous savez on
a chacun une chance formant on a une vie
en plus voilà donc ça c'est pour le
résumé un petit peu de ce qui se passe
donc là on va suivre direct là
demi-finale du loser bracket donc la
zavik contre Abdou et juste derrière on
suivra fille rousseja contre le gagnant
de cette demi-finale et demain ce sera
du coup la grande finale donc je vais
venir sur la scène avec les caméras les
joueurs qui sont toujours pas installés
qui font des va-et-vient j'ai toujours
pas les parties qui vont commencer
normalement les parties commencent
commence à 17h15 il me semble
donc on a un petit peu en avance donc
peut-être que je peux en profiter pour
vous parler un petit peu des sponsors
alors je pense que vous avez un petit
peu vu les vidéos j'avais mis des les
vidéos des des pubs avant de commencer à
représenter un petit peu l'événement et
ici c'est vrai que alors en tant que
sponsor on en a plein plein ici donc
vous avez vous voyez normalement
je vois pas les les logos dessinés sur
cette scène pourquoi donc
normalement attendez
c'est pas sur cette
il est jeune il est jeune
c'est quoi
logos
non c'est pas ça
[Musique]
de comprendre
quelque chose
ok il est de partout il n'est pas
c'est de voir pourquoi j'ai pas les
logos ici
il manque un truc je crois
alors je vais essayer de résoudre le
problème
[Musique]
je vais essayer de résoudre le problème
alors c'est ça en fait que j'ai pas
je vais vous les montrer
c'est quand même je pense plus sympa si
on les a
si je les mets là
je l'ai pourquoi je l'avais pas avancé
une grande question voilà vous avez les
logos qui sont qui sont placés ici je
vais me voir si dans l'autre salle ils
sont placés aussi et oui c'est le cas
alors je sais pas pourquoi ils étaient
pas là maintenant ils sont là donc les
logos qui sont en bas à droite qui vont
défiler un peu comme un diaporama
et donc tu essayes tout le monde connaît
je pense c'est le site qui était
le groupe Magnus on va dire alors
vous avez vu je pense aussi les pubs
c'est les sortes de petits de petits des
petites pièces
quelqu'un peut jouer faire des jeux je
les pubs après je vous la remonterai ici
on va attendre la prochaine
en dessous use bar vous avez ici après
je vous remettrai un petit peu les les
pubs vous verrez un petit peu ce que
tout c'est quoi correspond un peu tout
ça et je vous laisse vous montrer le
trophée alors c'est trop fait regardez
on a ici en fait par rapport à des entre
le format ici vous avez premier format
vous savez que les trois premiers de la
Division 1 ce qualifie pour la division
du prochain événement et le vainqueur de
la division 2 ce qualifiera aussi pour
la division le reste ça se qualifie lors
de Play lors de playing qui se joue
alors je vais vous montrer un petit peu
je crois que ça va être là voilà là vous
avez en fait les événements qui sont
passés avec le vainqueur de chaque
événement là le judo bear c'est celui
qui se joue actuellement qui finit le 3
septembre donc demain et ensuite sixième
événement qui aura lieu du 25 au 29
septembre et ce sera le dernier
événement avant la grande finale du au
16 septembre de décembre pardon pour
cette grande finale et ben les
organisateurs ils ont fait ce super
trophée que je vous montre ici c'est le
trophée qui a été proposé pour le
vainqueur du tournoi en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que
chaque joueur dans toutes les événements
à toutes les divisions et ben on
engrangé un certain nombre de points par
rapport à leur calife par rapport à leur
place respective dans chaque événement
et du coup ben là j'ai pas je crois que
j'ai pas le j'ai pas le
classement des points depuis le début de
l'événement mais il y a un classement
qui doit être quelque part et du coup ce
sera la coupe du grand vainqueur et vu
que quarantaine a gagné plusieurs fois
l'événement je pense qu'il est quand
même pas mal et les favoris pour gagner
pour gagner cet événement regarder 45 il
a déjà gagné deux fois l'événement
contre une une fois nord du beurk et
écarter il est encore en finale du grand
événement de cette division et on a
aussi
en demi-finale des losers donc si
ensuite qui va filou et ensuite il va
craindre à 2 donc à voir avoir en tout
cas encore beaucoup à faire ici pour
Abdou dans ce dans ce tournoi et on va
attendre du coup les parties qui
devraient commencer d'ici quelques
minutes alors je refais ça j'ai toujours
pas les parties chez moi
toujours pas les parties ici alors
bonjour à tous sur le chat installé il
m'a dit que le blitzer et salut Jim
barrette salut Dav du 56 alors je veux
dire un peu vos messages les amis qui
l'a dit attends
il est assez jeune
2 et 3 prochaine Carlson alors le
gagnant de la division 2
rejoint la division 1 lors de la
dernière édition par contre la division
3 je crois qu'elle n'est pas
qualificative et pour ça il y a des
plugins donc c'est un tournoi qui aura
lieu et après donc les places seront
donnés aux gens qui font les meilleurs
résultats dans
[Musique]
dans dans l'avènement quoi oui il a 17
ans il a 17 ans il a quasiment 2600 Elo
je crois qu'il a 25 60 exactement et en
fait moi je l'ai connu si vous voulez
via en fait via com donc il faisait
qu'il avait plus de 3000 € à chaque fois
et franchement hyper impressionnant et
[Musique]
du coup
je l'ai vu après participer au
championnat du monde de méditait rapide
et je me suis dit tiens ça va être sympa
de le voir jouer parce que il est hyper
impressionnant sur internet mais on ne
sait jamais vous savez des fois il est
l'heure sur Internet qui sont renforts
que sur internet donc c'était vraiment
un petit peu le pour ma part un peu le
gros le gros challenge et écouter en
blitz ça va pile au championnat du monde
il a été monstrueux et classé les
championnats du monde extrêmement
impressionnant donc il a confirmé ce que
j'avais déjà suivi sur Internet
et donc voilà alors la partie elle va
commencer
je vais essayer de vous voir les temps
qui vont arriver aussi des temps et donc
là David qui a quand même sorti dans ce
tournoi il a quand même sorti sortie
saut so ouest sortir quand même
donc
c'est pion il est en Division 1 quoi
donc division il faut aussi se qualifier
l'autre jour enfin hier on était avec
Laurent
sur le stream après c'est parti les
venus voir et l'idée c'est la première
fois qu'il arrivait à scanifier pour la
division 2 donc vous imaginez si un
super joueur comme Laurent puisque les
filles une seule fois dans la deux on
arrive pas à passer à la Une alors c'est
lui il en a une c'est que déjà sa place
il a bien gagné quoi c'est en tout cas
pas évident et alors la partie qui va
commencer alors normalement les couleurs
sont bonnes
basilique qui aura des blancs la
première partie qu'on trade alors est-ce
que vous avez des pronostics dans le
chat par rapport à cette finale est-ce
que vous avez un favori
moi j'en ai un gros
moi j'en ai un gros mais est-ce que vous
vous en avez si vous en avez un
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de cette
finale
est-ce que vous pensez que va réussir à
continuer son petit chemin où est-ce
qu'il y a sa story
Abdou qui sait qui s'est réveillé quand
même depuis depuis on va perdu 3-0
contre fille ou alors de quart de finale
des gagnants intérieur il a il est
revenu et il est sans pitié
il est sans pitié
donc oui alors pour moi le favori claire
c'est Abdou parce qu'il a déjà gagné une
édition
même en partie donc c'est tout il a 2730
et l'eau à peu près c'est un jeune qui
qui monte énormément bien sûr les aussi
mais un peu moins quand même donc moi
j'ai mon favori numéro 1 c'est évident
pour moi que
Abdou et favori ici mais bon c'est ça
reste pas clair vous savez que l'analyse
qui est là il est chaud il fait de
belles parties depuis qu'il est depuis
qu'il est là et on est capable de tout
mais deux parties vous aurez que deux
parties
aller-retour et en cas d'égalité sur
l'aller-retour et ben il y aura une
troisième partie en Armageddon avec
enchères je voudrais expliquerai un
petit peu comment se passe l'enchère en
cas de
en cas de si on y arrive quoi
et puis et puis donc là on a un
gambidame joué par les Blancs une
position assez tranquille vous voyez
position de candidates les noirs qui ont
joué avec G6 fou G7 et mis un fou en
réussissent donc c'est un système qui
est assez étrange on va dire
l'idée claire je pense de Abdou c'est de
demander
donc maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
est-ce qu'on va défendre ces quatre par
B3 par cavalier 5 où est-ce que B3 où
est-ce qu'on allait manger en D5 donc la
prise en dessin
c'est pas forcément la meilleure idée
c'est aplatit ça aplani un petit peu là
la position qui a eu B3 et du coup Abdou
en profite pour Joker
sur le cavalier et sur la diagonale qui
va pas tarder à s'ouvrir donc si je
mange dans le 4 par exemple alors je
sais pas si une bonne idée à avoir mais
on peut imaginer un truc comme ça il y a
pas cavalier des deux il y a le pion en
prise en
E4 mais il y a aussi un truc moins qui
m'interroge je me dis peut-être que un
truc plus tard sur le long terme avec C5
peut-être une bonne idée pourquoi parce
qu'en fait je veux profiter du fait que
la diagonale noire soit ouverte et pas
bien contrôlé pour essayer de faire C5
vite manger chacun va laisser 6 et
mettre la pression sur le sur l'option
des quatre j'ai pas du tout envie de
faire un coup comme fou F5 par exemple
parce que un jour je vais faire F3
et en fait j'ai réussi à récupérer le
récupérer le centre comme ça et plus
tard je pourrais pousser le centre
c'est deux peut-être qui peut aussi
gagner le pion avoir mais ce pion en 4
c'est pas forcément une bonne nouvelle
pour les Noirs c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut jouer de manière active
avec ses 5 on va voir un peu si c'est la
partie il y a pas encore joué sur sur
cavalucade j'imagine qu'il réfléchit à
Caval de 4 et il est à jeu du coup fou
B2 c'est un coup qui m'a l'air plus safe
plus solide surtout quand un joueur joue
tout tempo en face et je voulais truc un
peu bizarres comme ce qu'il a fait quand
même en début de partie ça assez bizarre
Abdou donc du coup je pense que fougue2
reste assez logique on garde sa position
bien solide et on va voir ce qui va se
passer plus tard
donc là cavalier 7 on peut imaginer
comme tours c'est un peut-être pour
préparer un éventuel ouverture de
colonnes plus tard voilà c'est le coca
qui a été joué donc très
logique là j'invente rien je sais de
placer des pièces vous savez quand on
est parti on sort le Cavaillon on s'en
rend les fous on voit qu'on met les
tours en jeu voilà il y a absolument
aucune difficulté donc cavalier F6 et
donc là on peut imaginer que il va
falloir manger en C3 pour amener l'autre
cavalier en E4 ça peut être une idée
assez sympa donc les Noirs généralement
sont un peu moins bien dans ces
positions pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
moins d'espace que les Blancs donc moins
d'espace dit moins de moins de cases
pour mes pièces donc si jamais j'arrive
à échanger quelques pièces pardon
cavalier prend cette roi suivi de
cavaliers 4
et ben je vais réussir à échanger des
pièces et donc avoir plus de cases pour
les pièces quand vous avez moins
d'espace ou l'adversaire et essayer de
changer les pièces c'est plutôt
plutôt un bon conseil que je vous donne
là quand vous manquez de l'espace et
changer les pièces après ça dépend
desquels il y a des bonnes pièces qu'il
faut pas échanger mais ici les cavaliers
ça peut être échanger vous voyez que la
case 4 là j'ai un cavalier en 4 et
l'autre cavalier vient en M6 pourquoi il
investisse parce qu'il veut venir à un
cadre j'ai déjà un cavalier en 4 vous
comprenez bébé qui voulait se
débarrasser lui cavalier pour mettre
l'autre en E4 et c'est pour ça qu'ici
les blancs en jeu cavaliers à 4 pour
éviter l'échange des pièces et je pense
ce que va faire ici
l'analyse peut-être alors on sait pas on
va voir
c'est avec une idée un jour toujours
avec cavaler ses 5 afin de
dire ok ok je veux bien changer mais en
contrepartie et ben j'ai mon fou qui va
s'ouvrir et mon fou ma rafale pas mal
moi que le fou B2 ici il a un peu
enfermé il est pas terrible mais on peut
accepter l'échange mais en ouvrant le
fou ça peut être une idée mais on peut
aussi jouer du lot de manière donc là
j'étais un peu je sais pas trop comment
il va vouloir la jouer il y a un coup
comme c'est prend des seins qui peut
être possible avec l'idée de faire plus
tard cavaler ses cinq et sur cavaler
prend ses cinq je prends de la tour et
je vais essayer de doubler voir tripler
sur la colonne C et rentrer et voir ce
qui se passe quoi donc avoir moi je suis
plus d'avis d'essayer de faire des prêts
parce que je pense à ce foulard et
j'aimerais bien l'ouvrir et
éventuellement un jour pouvoir les
changer contre le foie de verse pour
affaiblir un peu le renard donc dans
plusieurs idées intéressantes en tout
cas pour les blancs mais j'ai bien aimé
cette suite qui s'est passé avec les
noirs qui ont jeté 4 les blancs qui ont
joué le cavalier qui vient
qui avait des F6 et le cavalier A4 vous
voyez les cavaliers les Noirs cherchent
à échanger une part de cavalier alors
que des blancs ils veulent bien échanger
mais
[Musique]
ça dépend de la condition ici comme ça
non c'est 5 pourquoi pas c'est une
possibilité
donc Abdou qui réfléchit
B6 pour empêcher que c'est moche
pourquoi c'est moche parce que
plus tard je peux bon et Cavalo 5 qui
est possible en fait les cases blanches
sont faibles vous voyez j'ai la cavalier
qui peut être excessif la tour qui
indirectement aussi attaque C6 un fou
qui peut venir aussi attaquer rapidement
sur le case blanche alors pourquoi faut
assise parce qu'en fait vous voyez que
il va y avoir un débat bientôt sur la
colonne C qui va un jour s'ouvrir et en
fait l'idée de de faire faux assis c'est
un péché les noirs de faire pour C8 pour
contester la colonne ouverte donc il y a
plein plein d'idées possibilités ici qui
a eu le tour c'est une ici qui a l'air
plus normal et noir anticipe un petit
peu la
possibilité pouvoir ouvrir la colonne C
un mémoire sont déjà présent
[Musique]
voyez les Noirs veulent à tout prix à
changer échanger un cavalier c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment ce qu'ils
veulent faire et donc là moi je vois
bien un petit coup de cavaler des trois
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
c'est assez logique par rapport à tout
ce quad depuis le début les blancs
visent la caisse c'est 5 avec leur
cavaliers tout à l'heure alors que noir
veulent à tout prix échanger des pièces
donc cavaler des trois malheur logique
dans l'approche de la partie après à ce
qu'il va jouer c'est pas sûr du tout
mais ça m'a l'air une réaction assez
logique
en plus avec cavalier de 3 donc avait
l'avant étant F3 un jour appel quand je
viens ici plus tard j'ai essayé de faire
F3 pour chaque cavalier et ça c'est
intéressant aussi parce que
je cavalie il peut être embêtant et si
je fais F3 bah il va reculer on sait pas
trop où et les cavaliers ben vraiment
une cases et bon écoutez à voir
donc moi je voudrais bien un petit coup
cavaler des trois après je sais pas du
tout ce qu'il a en tête c'est pas du
tout là il faut calculer il y a
peut-être des choses qu'il faut calculer
du style prise prix peut-être du B5 j'en
sais rien c'est tout cassé parce que là
il se passe un truc c'est qu'en plus il
a joué
il y avait le vis-à-vis tout à l'heure
c'était pas un vis-à-vis il y avait un
vis-à-vis mais il y avait un cavalier en
M6 tout à l'heure quand je parlais quand
je vous ai dit quand il a fait cavalier
A4 je vous disais ah oui ca va les
prendre qu'elle va les prendre puis on
prend j'ouvre mon fou c'est bien c'est
beau mais maintenant que non on fait
cavaler des 7 dans la différence c'est
que si jamais un jour je joue qu'elle va
laisser 5 imaginons le devoir prenne je
prends une cavaliers le cavalier prend
alors je vais faire un cours au hasard
juste pour voir
pour vous montrer
il est plus défendu
alors tout à l'heure je clouais le
cavalier F6 sur le fou bon je pourrais
faire à l'envers bien sûr je pourrais
faire ça
manger des pions
j'aurais pas un cavalier super actif en
B2 c'est pas c'est pas super mais vous
voyez que maintenant grâce à cavalier
fd7 les Noirs ont aussi mis en place
leur vis-à-vis et donc maintenant la
casse c'est ça qui est plus dur à
atteindre tout à l'heure
voilà donc kv3 comme était joué GF3
toute une menace et un coup assez
logique très souvent dans ce type de
position plus tard on va essayer déjà
que 4
plus tard en préparant mais ça peut être
en tout cas c'est pas ça peut faire
partie d'un plan ce petit coin F3 donc
je pense ici que
je pense ici que la pollution elle est
pas mal pour les blancs j'aime bien ce
que fait pour l'instant l'azalique
il joue de manière solide qui joue des
coups très très cohérent
très logique
et Abdou qui joue assez vite pour
l'instant
la nuit d'avance
il essaie de [__] mécanité il essaye
de changer des pièces il essaye de
comment on continue la partie là
qu'est-ce qu'on va jouer avec les Noirs
c'est pas évident
mange où ça
comment est-ce qu'on joue ça je vois pas
trop l'idée là
c'est 5 je suis trop de fois dessus
ça pourrait être logique c'est simple
pour avoir le fou mais
je suis trop de fois dessus
parce qu'en plus c'est ça qui peut être
possible l'idée c'est que je chasse ton
cavalier puis après je pourrais manger
ces cinq une fois de plus parce que le
cavalier sera parti
donc c'est pas trop possible
ça je pensais à B5 mais bon un truc
comme ça mais c'est un truc comme ça
tout à l'heure avec l'idée d'essayer de
se débarrasser de ce pur là
[Musique]
pour un jour ils mettent un cavalier
mettre un truc il mettre un fou je sais
pas
j'ai ma case mais moi aussi j'ai une
case la tête plus tard avoir je sais pas
avec les noirs
peut-être qu'il veut jouer 5 sur le long
terme c'est une possibilité ce fruit mal
placé mais attention Roger 4
ce fou qui peut qui peut à tout moment
être être mal placé et salut
à toi j'espère que tu vas bien
bienvenue à tous un de ceux qui arrivent
sur le chat bienvenue à vous donc
aujourd'hui on a deux matchs en
perspective on a lasalik contre à
le gagnant de ce match affrontera à
l'IRESA pour la finale du bracket des
perdants et ce vainqueur entre les
raisins et le vainqueur de ce match
affrontera Carlsen demain
avec karting qui qui est qui est
[Musique]
sur une forme olympique franchement
quand on a vu jouer hier c'était
impressionnant c'est souvent précédent
quand on regarde ça mais hier c'était
quelque chose
a été joué
qu'est-ce qu'on va jouer ici avec les
Noirs donc le coup F3 c'est toujours un
coup qu'on a envie de faire pour chasser
le cavalier et c'est de prendre un peu
d'espace mais attention avec mon four en
B2 j'ai peur qu'un jour peut-être après
F3 cavalier qui bouge là ou là on peut
il peut y avoir plus tard un foie H6 qui
pourra attaquer l'option E3 c'est une
idée un voyant en fait quand je joue F3
l'avantage c'est que je cherche le
cavalier et que je veux juste pour E4
mais l'inconvénient c'est que je laisse
aussi le cadre noir un peu faible donc
c'est pas toujours évident il y a eu G4
waouh j'ai 4 joué par vasalick et avec
qui a pas peur et apparemment fou si
c'était une erreur alors incroyable
merci beaucoup skybloz pour ton raid
merci à toi enfin
un petit sauce caille blues
hop
j'espère qu'on s'est bien passé en tout
cas bienvenue à tous sur le stream nous
on regarde la zavik contre a + autorov
et j'ai un truc à voir avec l'ordinateur
donc je vais tricher un peu
je vais pas mettre l'ordi mais là je
vais le mettre parce que G4 je vois que
l'ordi il met pour l'interrogation à
vous aussi alors que fauché c'est un peu
la seule case de mon fou en fait donc
c'est un peu bizarre et apparemment le
seul coup là
et mais avant de faire faux F5 c'était
bizarre ok apparemment B5 c'est le seul
coup
trop bizarre
c'est chaud et apparemment fou aussi
c'est une faute parce que cavalier F4
donc cavalier qui vient attaquer le fou
et le fou qui est qui est pas défendable
donc on va réussir à le manger un peu
quand je veux
cavaler prend aussi sur un fou prendre 3
intermédiaire ça fera un chèque
comment est-ce que je continue ici
j'aime beaucoup la pollution des blancs
[Musique]
gros favori quand même
pour ce match mais vu ce qui se passe
dans cette première partie
il avait fait mentiellement
là
comment je peux continuer si je prends
bêtement il faut prendre ici un
une petite une petite chose
parce que maintenant en faisant ça et
ben je mangeais le fou je suis assez
content j'ai la paire de fou les gaz
blanche que je pourrais faire ça pour
défendre là et faire F3 c'est la valeur
assez sympa pour les blancs
donc il a commencé avec avec F3 le
problème F3 c'est que maintenant il peut
plus manger là parce qu'il faut prendre
un chèque
c'est un pion pour toi
apparemment faute à cause de pourquoi F4
bien joué et là on va casser un peu la
structure et des prends ces quatre donc
là il y a plein de coups à pointeur
avant c'est difficile à comprendre ces
positions
assez difficiles à comprendre ici il
fallait jeter un de ces 7
pour attaquer le pion et
c'est hyper hyper compliqué à comprendre
dans l'idée pour pour qu'on puisse un
petit peu pourquoi l'ordinateur donne ce
type de coût en fait ici avec avec H5
l'idée c'est qu'ils veulent attaquer les
pions G4 par toutes les pièces avec
l'idée que sur G5 et ben je bouge le
Cavalaire je peux aller un peu de
partout mais plus tard regardez comme là
par exemple je peux recycler après sur
la case F5 et la structure de pion des
blancs elle est complètement cassée donc
là ça a pas du tout pour pour les blancs
et bon c'est pas évident donc là il y a
eu prise ici et B5 on en a parlé
prix
ça a l'air hyper logique en tout cas
quand on voit cette position des blancs
le rock des blancs qui est complètement
ouvert et ben avec les noirs on a envie
d'ouvrir la position donc c'est
exactement ça de se passer et Abdou qui
joue B5 le problème de B5 c'est qu'ici
2000 a vu qu'un jeu de coup de dessin et
des cinq
classes comme nous met un petit point
d'exclamation on va essayer ensemble de
comprendre pourquoi
sur pion prend là
c'est quand même tout en l'air
si tu prends là je prends là ça c'est
clair que on a une bonne structure
derrière par contre tu prends là
je peux manger ici
est-ce que je peux avoir mieux je
regarde un peu
prends la
il faut manger là en fait ouais c'est le
mien oui
c'est vrai que
Dame des quatre et j'ai 5 avec des
menaces de matelas haut ça a l'air quand
même assez facile à jouer pour les pour
les blancs et après
serein dans dans cette partie après des
cinq
après les cinq il est il est pas bien
salut les mots
merci merci beaucoup pour ton message
ben écoute ça
ça me fait très plaisir et oui c'est
vraiment ce petit
comment dire ça faisait longtemps que
j'attendais tu vois donc
c'est un soulagement quoi c'est un
soulagement finalement on l'a fait c'est
tellement de de
fois où j'étais très très proche et que
j'ai tout raté finalement le fait de
l'avoir ça
ça nous rassure un peu et ça fait
plaisir
finalement donc voilà donc là je l'ai
pas encore officiellement si vous allez
voir ce que ça de la feed je suis encore
maître fille mais mais ça va arriver là
on a j'attends juste la fille que la
fille de fasse les démarches
administratives
et ça sera fait dans quelques mois
je prends un 4
si il prend 4 je fais je fais des
problèmes c'est bien ça Mr dark
pardon c'est bien ça et si tu manges là
bah là tu vas bien que j'ai la carte de
fou il y a tout qui est ouvert chez toi
tu as aucun pion lié c'est un peu triste
donc je peux manger tous les pions j'ai
plein de coussins pas
d'apprendre un cadre d'un coup je peux
aussi faire Dame des quatre avec
tout à l'heure G5 et dames 30 là haut je
peux faire j'ai 5 d'abord puis des
quatre
je pense que tous les coups de la roue
même si c'est ça
ma souris cinq fou c'est 4 il y a plein
de choses qui ont l'air bien ici pour
les blancs et là c'est tu as pas besoin
de de d'être encore du monde pour te
rendre compte que cette position elle
est problématique pour les noirs que des
problèmes de partout
comment il va réagir sur des cinq c'est
assez hyper chaud je pense qu'il faut
manger quand même ici en dessin qui
après
prise et après il faut
il faut trouver une solution
peut-être manger un
ça permet de désorganiser un petit peu
la pollution blanche bon
moi j'aimerais essayer d'empêcher au
maximum l'attaque des blancs en tout cas
la ralentir dans ma 5 ça empêche 3
mais bon on sent que il y a trop de
problèmes quoi même ça je peux
pas défendre mon cavalier etc trop
compliqué salut à tous salut Sharko
salut prince salut lucopat
c'est la partie je suis un génie
je suis un génie c'est pas un bon coup
mais je devienne des coups
comment ça m'a l'air logique parce que
je vais empêcher voyez j'ai bien compris
que la menace était 4
et j'ai 5 et chasse le cavalier et je
mate la haute avec mon fou madame ça on
l'a compris que c'était les blancs du
coup ton coincé
j'ai encore l'idée de faire ça et ça
mais du coup là j'ai dans ma 5 alors là
ouais et là il fallait jouer à H5 quand
même bon c'est juste incompréhensible
comme dame bu c'était débile ou pas
essayer de faire tourner en plus
apparemment
l'ordinateur il est
il s'en fout complètement de mon coup il
fait ça et ça en fait il s'en fout
complet en bas je cherche des
solutions alors dame D1 a été joué ici
alors dans 25 il fallait faire quoi
demain 5 pardon à la place de Massac
H5 mais bon pour moi ça comprend aussi
compréhensible
humainement humainement c'est quand même
dur
j'aime pas mais mon ordinateur il
calcule tout il dit bon ça va ça va
c'est trop dur
en fait cette position il y a trop de
problèmes pour les noirs du coup un
joueur un joueur même si c'est abuser en
face un humain c'est beaucoup trop dur
pour pour les Noirs il y a trop de
problèmes en fait
j'ai la paire de fou je l'attaque
les espaces le fou aussi s'il a pas de
cases
sont même pas bonnes si on peut j'enlève
la paire de fou j'enlève la taxe sur des
cases noires
et en plus le point noir est tellement
facile
je vais faire ça pardon je vais faire ça
je vais faire ça les coups sont
tellement faciles
il y a eu le tour c'est de jouer tempo
est-ce que un bouton vous n'aurez pas
envie de d'aller sacrifier la tour sur
sur un fou
du style
voilà j'ai quand même le tour des deux
qui peut arriver
voilà on va voir ce qu'il va manger là
où est-ce qu'il va jouer tour des deux
c'est deux j'ai quand même du G5 qui
peut arriver alors c'est la partie
attention que là je te reprends en trois
qui peut être une menace
donc on est trois d'un point de 3 et
d'un grand cavalier attention ça fait
surcharge sur la dalle je sais pas je
peux pas défendre toutes mes pièces en
même temps
et je sais pas du tout parce que
Foussais 3 attaque toutes les pièces
j'ai probablement encore
pour prendre des trois si je mange là tu
prends ma dame si je mange là tu manges
là oui donc je peux pas faire genre de
choses et je retourne là il faut trouver
une solution pour pour les blancs parce
que pour là c'est une grosse menace
et je peux pas bouger mon cavalier parce
que sinon cavalier du style cavalier
c'est 3 ben je perds le fou dommage et
si le boulot cavaler par ici il y aura
cavalier princesse
[Applaudissements]
qui a trouvé une défense active très
intéressante
qui pose des problèmes un petit peu
à Las Vegas maintenant
il y aura je prends un
à la fin
comment ça il y aura japonais si c'est
la fin
oui non ok mais
[Musique]
peut-être que là c'est vrai que là ça
marche peut-être pas acheter de la
de faire ça sur G5 peut-être qu'il y a
un truc
si je bouge mon cavale l'ordi n'aime pas
du tout hein
si je prends là prends là je prends la
je prends là
je me suis quand même pas mal défendu
alors c'est que pour la qualité
que j'ai donné j'ai quand même du jeu
même ça c'est un coup
qui menace perpétuelle
dans la chambre et on fait les
allers-retours
et puis si jamais tu veux vraiment
l'empêcher et ben je pourrais plus tard
manger ici et j'ai quand même pris des
petits pions
ouvert et les pions pas si clair
il y a eu ici F5 et apparemment c'est le
coût de l'ordi il est en vers le coup
attention jacinthe qu'il fallait je
crois
c'est encore extrêmement compliqué
ouais c'est perdu
c'est moi qui te matte
sont vraiment fort pour trouver des
ressources
donc F5 c'est le coup jouer je prends un
F5 forcée et maintenant j'ai 5 ouais
monstrueux monstrueux en fait c'est la
même ligne que tout à l'heure c'est
pareil c'est le même coup sauf que on
est en fait F5 d'abord
pour aller menacer
une perpétuelle
ou est-ce que c'est trop trop dur
c'est complexe
c'est la partie prise d'un point H4 tout
F2 donc là il y a plus d'échec parce que
j'ai tout réussi
il y a le fou qui visait là-haut la tour
ici
on voit la jauge qui donne à David un
énorme
avantagement j'ai qu'une qualité de plus
mais il y a plein de pions pour la
qualité c'est pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout clair mais c'est vrai que
regarder si les dames sont échangées
pareil il y a ça qui tombe et après j'ai
deux fusées qui ont décollé jusque
[Musique]
jusqu'à la promotion
en fait
je crois que c'est complètement terminé
cette partie
je crois que c'est fini
tu dois aller ici
et
ma souris qui fait que j'ai pas de case
là
[Musique]
et si je vais là il y a ça
donc tourage 2 je suis obligé de faire
la carte de ma fuite quoi c'est très
très moche
rien
en plus sur la cadre
quelle horreur tu rentres à la maison tu
pousses le pion c'est fini
franchement à David Master Class
incroyable
vous savez que j'avais annoncé tout à
l'heure un grand
favorisateur Rohff
et pour l'instant et ben écoutez il est
en train de me faire complètement mentir
c'est 5 bien joué et la tour je veux
il y a pas d'échec la Dame Blanche
contre toutes les cases des échecs des
noirs
donc ton jeu de menace
[Musique]
la finale elle est perdue
je mange et je pousse des pions
je sais pas comment il peut se
déformation voilà même
là enfin je vais
ça a l'air
aussi dame
salut à tous c'est lucaspard bienvenue à
tous
dames et 6
doit gagner mais je pense encore plus
fort là
encore plus fort ben là c'est le coup
qui joue
et là c'est ma tendeur hop prime
et jusqu'au maths franchement très très
grosse partie en tout cas de la zavik
qui était pour ma part pas du tout
partie favori lors de ce match bon il
fait quand même une belle compétition
j'ai rencontré un petit peu son parcours
regardez son parcours à la vie il a
perdu son premier match 3 2 contre
Kawana donc c'est vrai qu'il était parti
jusqu'au Armageddon et donc armage est
donc courte car voilà ça monte quand
même que
il fait un gros match ce car voilà c'est
quand même numéro 2 ou 3 mondial
actuellement il faut regarder mais bon
c'est c'est monstrueux quoi et ensuite
après cette défaite il est venu dans le
bracket perdant il a gagné 2-1 contre la
bataille
ensuite il a joué contre saw donc so
Wesley c'est aussi un des meilleurs
joueurs
du monde mais surtout aussi online et
donc il a encore gagné 2-1 et maintenant
qui est une grande machine aussi grosse
machine de c'est un jeune qui progresse
qui n'arrête pas de progresser et de
débouillir et la dernière gagné une
édition il y a quelques mois de cet
endroit et donc là il vient de battre
arzottov dans la première partie donc il
est vraiment un beau parcours dès que
quand une seule partie entre les deux
joueurs et
si Apple Store gagne cette partie et ben
on va avoir droit à
marma gedon pour départager les deux
joueurs par contre si Abdou ne n'aime
pas sa partie et ben à David se
qualifiera pour la finale des perdants
contre Ali resa firugia
donc on aura on n'a pas d'horaire ça se
voit tout à l'heure dès que les matchs
seront terminés
selle
je vais changer les résultats
[Musique]
je vais mettre le petit 1
à donner lasalik c'est le casse pas les
patates quoi comme mesure de sécurité en
ligne comme ça alors pas mal
déjà il y a un délai de une minute entre
les joueurs enfin entre les parties et
nous les commentaires donc on est nul de
délai
les joueurs aussi ont une caméra sur eux
la caméra vous la voyez elle est elle
est elle est sur le stream mais il y
aura aussi une autre caméra qui est
derrière eux en fait et qui filme leur
bureau et leur mouvement en fait comme
si j'avais une caméra qui filmait qui me
filmait de deux ou de travers pour voir
vraiment mes écrans pour voir tout ce
que je fais
de plus et ben les joueurs doivent
partager leur écran avec avec
l'organisation arbitres qui font partie
tout ça pour vérifier qu'il se passe
rien et en plus de tout ça et ben il y a
un check avant les parties il y a un
check les joueurs doivent montrer la
salle où ils sont et dans mon trou aussi
sur ordinateur vous savez le gestion des
tâches dans montrer que vraiment il y a
rien d'ouvert donc c'est quand même
assez contrôlé après bon bah si tu veux
tricher
je pense qu'il y a toujours moyen de
tricher mais
à ce niveau là dans cet endroit là les
joueurs sont très connus
je pense qu'il y a aucune
aucune aucune chance qu'un genre comme
ça l'Autriche hier on avait Laurent
Freyssinet qui est venu une grande
visite après son match contre
contre rockidoff un joueur ouzbek et il
nous a parlé un petit peu de ces mesures
en Dietrich et il disait qu'il se
sentait hyper bien dans cet endroit
online parce que quand tu joues il est
sûr à 100% que
que il y a pas de triche il sent
vraiment en sécurité et il sent qu'il
joue ils font n'importe quoi tous les
deux et que s'amuse quoi mais on sent
vraiment que qu'il y a pas de triche en
tout cas c'était son sentiment à lui et
il est très confiant à ce niveau là donc
c'est assez positif quand même tout ça
et encore une fois c'est le tournoi qui
sont online mes qualificatifs et pour se
qualifier dans les premières poules
surtout il faut vraiment vraiment être
un excellent joueur
de niyazaki et Abdou ils l'ont quand
même pas mal démontré par le passé dans
les tournois IRL notamment le chocolat
du monde de Blitz lazalée qu'il avait
été monstrueux il a fait une performance
à plus de 27,50 donc même online enfin
online ou IRL les deux joueurs sont sont
extrêmement forts donc il y a pas de
doute en tout cas à avoir dans aucun des
matchs
salut à toi Corto M34
j'espère que vous allez bien tous sur le
chat j'espère que vous passez un
agréable après-midi
et donc la partie la deuxième partie qui
va bientôt bientôt commencer alors je
partirai pas en pause parce que là ça
fait voilà j'en ai arrivé par contre je
vais quand même vous mettre une pub vous
savez que avec avec
tous les les sponsors qu'on a sur
cet événement et ben on est obligé de
mettre des pubs et d'ailleurs même je
suis même obligé de noter à quelle heure
je passe les pubs donc je suis désolé
c'est pas contre vous c'est pas pour
vous mais je dois mettre des pubs donc
je vous envoie une petite et je reviens
d'ici 2 minutes mais je pars pas en
pourrir je suis devant l'ordinateur je
reste là promis je ne bouge pas
hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour
vous avez pu observer je pense les
différents
sponsors les pubs qui étaient
donnés avec et la prochaine partie je
pense qu'il va démarrer
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
je cherche le hop genre qui sont prêts
en tout cas à repartir mais j'ai pas
encore la partie qui est lancée
donc là je vous rappelle c'est en deux
parties gagnantes le premier à un point
et demi
donc Abdou factor of a perdu la première
partie avec les Noirs donc dans la
deuxième il aura les blancs et il aura
obligation de gagner pour arriver à un
départage Armageddon
si gagne pas cette partie et ben ça sera
Denis qui sera opposé à
des raisins physio lors de cette finale
déperdant et du coup on a ici on a la
partie qui va débuter
à l'instant
donc
qu'est-ce que va jouer à deux au premier
coup E4 D4 C4 cavalier
c'est un joueur qui peut absolument tout
jouer
alors que je prépare plutôt bien qui est
extrêmement sérieux
dans ces ouvertures en préparation dans
tout ce qui fait donc qu'est-ce qui nous
a concocté ici
notre
joueur ouzbek
donc à noter qu'elle Store c'est c'était
le premier échec qui est de les pics de
l'équipe olympique 12kistan qui a gagné
la médaille d'or en 2022
D4 a été joué et on repart sur cavalière
6 C4 cavaler C3 c'est une ragosine avec
fubé 4 donc c'est de la guerre plein de
possibles prend ces trois qui a un grand
coup ma prise d'un point D5 qu'avait le
4 aussi qui se joue pas mal
cavalier
prise prise B6 fois si je crois que
c'est une grande ligne ici c'est ce qui
va être joué mais c'est soit c'est pas
toujours et aussi c'est ça qui se jouent
pas mal avec les Noirs c'est un service
de pions souvent pour ouvrir le jeu vous
voyez que les Noirs ici ont une position
ok et les pièces sont quasiment toutes
sorties alors que les blancs ils ont
structure qui est très solide ils ont la
paire de fou et du coup pour essayer de
bousculer un peu tout ça les noirs
peuvent avoir envie de vite ouvrir la
position qu'il faut assise pour un jour
essayer de d'évoquer le roi blanc et je
crois que c'est ça quoi aussi fait
partie des candidats il me semble je
suis quasi sûr
un peu dans mes souvenirs il y avait
aussi un coup avec Dame dessin qu'un
jour mais je sais pas je sais pas ce que
soit ici dans cette position là
il y avait un fou F4 fois 6 d'un point
c'est ça que j'avais déjà vu avec tour
celite j'avais déjà vu une ligne comme
ça à l'époque je travaille et ça je
travaille cette position avec avec les
Noirs mais maintenant on peut joue plus
donc travailler plein de lignes pour ne
jamais le jouer je suis comme ça
mais deux du coup c'est pas un truc que
je connais je savais que les Noirs mais
l'idée de fouter deux pourraient être un
jour vu que les Noirs ils ont une idée
de faire ces cinq sur le long terme
peut-être que du coup c'est 3 serait
logique pour essayer de sur ces cinq
plus tard pouvoir ouvrir ce food de
cases noires donc xdmc2
maintenant comment est-ce qu'on continue
ce qu'on joue ces cinq est-ce qu'on joue
cavalier 7 pour gs5
pour ramener la pièce sur la colonne je
pense que laisser le foot là c'est pas
mal parce que sur trois j'aurais
toujours faux points et ça va déroquer
le roi blanc donc ça m'a l'air
pas mal et aussi cavaler le 17 avec tour
C8 éventuellement pour le C5 ou pardon
un sourire encore flanché une course C5
alors intéressant envoyer un vis-à-vis
de la dame ici si jamais j'avais une
tour assez vite mais je sais pas trop
mettre ce cavalier ces petits problèmes
des Noirs dans la position comment
est-ce qu'on continue ici
alors je sais que c'est ça que c'est un
coup un coup qui des fois peut être joué
mais qui avait les BD7 ici à l'art quand
même extrêmement
logique et sérieux à part qu'à valider 7
et c'est 5 je vois pas trop ce qu'on
peut jouer d'autres cette dame des cinq
pourrait se centraliser un peu les
pièces
sachant qu'il y a pas de cavaliers en B1
pour vivre en C3 on ne peut pas jouer 4
D5 fait sens aussi avec cavalue 4
éventuellement pour aller manger de la
la paire de fou blanche
c'était pas trop en tout cas Abdou ici
tout tempo il déballe la prépa il
connaît très bien ce qu'il fait il joue
très très vite et ça vise un petit peu
Denis lasagnes
qui a un coup qui est très logique très
normal et le 4e
donc E4 il se laisse se dire ok donc ça
souvent on voit au stade souvent dans le
dans le Benco aussi dans le camping
ou avec les Blancs on fait exprès de se
faire dévoquer pour après sortir avec le
roi en G2 et placer les tours au centre
donc c'est sûrement l'idée ici que à
peu près
parce que j'empêche le 4 c'était mon
idée tout à l'heure j'avais vu le 4 j'ai
4 3 qui est pas mal donc c'est ça pas la
prophylaxie empêcher un petit peu les
idées de l'adversaire
donc
c'est la partie et maintenant bon j'ai
quand même envie de faire [__] en F1
par principe pour dire OK
mais c'est toujours pas ça c'est pour
jouer peut-être plutôt fou B7 mais bon
[Musique]
je sais pas
avoir faut prendre la fin
tu es primé
et maintenant c'est pour C8 j'ai
l'impression qu'avec ce centre des
blancs il faut essayer d'aller vite
peut-être c'est simple du coup c'est 5
faut voir il faut calculer il y a plein
de coups là il peut y avoir du E5
et pas mal de réponses possibles
même si des sacs étaient pas un coup
ouais le style ça c'est
pas du tout ça c'était juste mon opinion
j'ai essayé de faire marche plus
cavalier j'ai 5 ou tourner un rapide et
quand même pas mal de pièces sur la
colonne des mais l'ordinateur il s'en
fout complètement il dit qu'il y a rien
donc ouais c'est cinq à l'air pas mal de
dessin
et ben un jour je vais casser là et
c'est de me ramener les pièces en jeu le
roi blanc est mal placé c'est ça va être
une suite
qui peut être joué en tout cas les noirs
qui sont un peu mal autant lesquels 5
minutes de retard dans une partie de 15
minutes ça commence à faire beaucoup
pour faire un peu attention
mais si la zavik il sait qu'il doit pas
perdre c'est à dire que si il fait match
nul
et ben il sera qualifié pour la finale
contre
8 a été joué donc souvent un secours et
pour jouer deux choses il y a le 5e
menacées mais aussi cavalier fuite qui
peut apprendre H7 ou éventuellement un
jour venir en G6 et défendre le roi noir
donc c'est un coup assez souple
donc tourner et bien je tempo il y a un
vis-à-vis entre la tour
et la dame ce qui
a un site pas trop les Noirs à jeu sans
que vous voyez sur le sein qui regarde
un problème sur
son vis-à-vis alors pas du tout envie de
le faire et c'est pour cette raison là
qu'il a le dessin pour empêcher un peu
E5 donc là plusieurs idées soit en
complexe c'est 5 mais c'est ça que c'est
pareil toujours ce vis-à-vis qui est
assez embêtant
pour sortir du vis-à-vis ça me set c'est
le coup après la musette
C5 on n'est pas sûr donc dan C8 a été
joué c'est pas le coup qui nous faisait
plus plaisir de jouer mais il faut
s'enlever du nettoiage et peut-être que
c'est 5 maintenant va être une menace
pour les Noirs donc c'est ça qui est un
coup mais j'ai aussi un B7 qui peut
aussi être une idée d'un B7 qui vient
attaquer le pion 4 qui qui se place me
renseigner
donc c'est un peu lent mais ça va avec
le roi blanc est encore en F1 ce qui
veut dire que
le plan de noir est lent ce roi F1 et
ben je pense qu'on peut se permettre ce
genre de choses
parce que pas bien développé même dans
ma cise est chèques peut être une V1
avec ces cinq avec rapidement pour ces 8
il y a plein d'idées pour les Noirs je
pense qu'il a pris son noir elle est pas
si mal ici en fait
je pense peut-être pas mal au cœur on
avait une idée
pour mettre tout droit et remplacer un
peu le roi mais maintenant que je vois
la dame C8 je me dis mais j'ai trois
pour se mettre sur carte blanche
maintenant est-ce que vraiment on a
envie de faire ranger deux
je suis pas sûr
je suis pas sûr parce que les Noirs
arrivent trop vite je pense
donc comment est-ce qu'on joue avec les
Blancs
pas facile hein
[Musique]
pas facile
on va se beau centre de pion blanc ici
mais en fait ce centre il est un peu
faible après c'est simple après dans le
B7 après ce genre de coup noir on a
vraiment l'impression que
que
[Musique]
pas si mal que ça en tout cas
salut les 9 et ça lévita faim
pourra-t-il jouer contre Magnus ah oui
c'est bien ça encore parce que moi j'ai
pas eu ton message
donc le gagnant de perdant c'est Ali
resa
et
qui va affronter le gagnant de ce
matelas
donc encore deux matchs avant de savoir
qui jouera contre Magnus demain
d'ailleurs demain j'en profite demain le
stream n'est pas à 17h c'est assez
bizarre mais la finale en fait tous les
jours sont à 17h sauf le dernier jour
c'est à 19h c'est un peu plus loin un
peu plus tard je sais pas pourquoi il en
est 19h j'en ai aucune idée mais demain
la finale entre Magnus et l'autre
personne qui sera là je sais pas encore
qui c'est et ben ce sera à 19h demain
et pas à 17h ça va changer
H4 a été joué par
Abdou santorov et H4 c'est un coup qui
est assez logique au final pourquoi
c'est logique parce qu'en fait on a bien
compris que j'ai trois ici était une
faiblesse parce que sur facebook
j'allais enfin moi à l'encontre tous les
principes et il y a des vis-à-vis de
partout il y a plus en cas de FM etc et
du coup H4 pour mon roi il rentre en G1
en fait rock c'est bon j'ai OK et la
tour qui pourra partir par H3 et G3 et
taper sur le roi en anges 8 donc c'est
intéressant de faire H4 pendant H4 tour
H3 tramasori excusez-moi j'en peux plus
H4 tour H3 tours J3
une possibilité ou alors aussi H4 H5
essayer de pousser l'option le plus loin
possible pour créer des faiblesses sur
le roi noir ça sent surtout que une fois
Gray en H6 et ben les gaz noir c'est
ouvert
là haut et le il est noir de dispose
plus de fou de cases noires j'aime bien
c'est 5 donc avec mon relève la réaction
au centre logique
et maintenant cavalier G5 qui va menacer
un petit mat en H7 tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit
et ben il y a plusieurs idées avec toi 8
c'était l'idée
de menacer éventuellement E5 pour venir
contester le centre mais aussi de faire
cavalier F8 pour un rejoint venir
défendre le pion H7 ou alors arrivé en
cavalier en G6 donc c'est un quoi c'est
souple ça je l'avais dit et du coup
arrivé dans cette position
après cavalier J5 qui me laisse
discrètement d'un point H7 et bien les
noirs n'ont pas joué cavalier fut que
j'avais j'allais proposer qui avait les
filles d'ici avait l'air quand même très
très logique un temps défendre le pion
H7 etc mais ici il y a eu à la place du
coup F5 qui me fait peur personnellement
mais d'un autre côté je comprends très
très bien regardez bien c'est que il
empêche d'en prendre un H7 coupe la
diagonale de la dame et il me lasse H6
pour chasser le cavalier donc vous savez
quand un pion avant de deux cases et que
je me retrouve à côté à Campion et ben
j'ai le droit à ce tour de jeu j'ai le
droit de manger en passant donc ici
ça a été joué et fils a été joué donc là
vous allez me dire oui mais le purifier
autour du roi sont pas si faibles parce
que les Blancs disposent pas du fond de
case blanche mais ici ce pion il est
faible ça c'est fait c'est un fait mais
en fait ce que noir veulent c'est ouvrir
la position parce que le roi blanc en F1
et ben il est très très mal placé donc
je suis d'accord avec les noirs de
mourir un peu la rose et de m'affaiblir
un peu les pions mais à contrepartie je
sais que j'aurais du jeu sur ton roi des
trucs des qu'avec qui vont arriver et
que du coup ça va être compliqué je le
sais donc du coup F5 je trouve que c'est
très malin
pour cette raison là
c'est 5 que je trouve un peu bizarre je
regardais les dames pour attaquer mais
ok
donc moi j'aime bien garder les dames
avec les Noirs parce que l'idée de
mettre créer des problèmes sur case
blanche et sur les pions isolés c'est
pour ouvrir un petit peu avec Madame ma
tour ouvrir un petit peu les colonnes et
tout ça mais des fois j'ai changé les
dames et ben on garde ses problèmes à
vie mais c'est vrai qu'en contrepartie
je suis la colonne B et le pion B2 qui
est toujours une faiblesse on peut
imaginer un jour un tour B3 qui peut
arriver que le tour en B8 manger B2 dans
sa position j'ai le pion en E5 qui est
quand même faible et qui risque de
rester faible pendant un bon moment d'en
faire va falloir que les Noirs
jouent de manière assez solide parce que
un petit pion évite perdu
cette position un pion est vite perdu
vous voyez que j'ai les idées avec
éventuellement trois H3
autour des trois même tour C3 c'était
valait parfait les pions en E5 et en C5
moi ils me font peur je me dis que
je me dis que c'est pion un jour peuvent
poser problème
a été joué
tout reprend le 4 qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pas évident
[Musique]
ça porte un nom deux pions isolés à une
colonne descart
dans cette position je crois pas mais il
y a des finales ou des pions ou ses
pions peuvent avoir un nom c'est
vraiment final de roi on va passer des
pions les pions électriques
c'est un final de roi imaginons
imaginons il y a plus de pièces il y a
que des pions ici et le roi noir et loin
mais Simon roi arrivé ici pour manger le
pur là je pourrais rester quatre
et du coup si tu manges le pion E5 et
qu'on pion
en fait les pions sont déconnectés parce
qu'ils sont pas ils sont pas ensemble
mais si tu vas manger un je pousse
l'autre comme par je mets je me le droit
ici pour aller manger le pion c'est 5 et
ben je joue
le pion je fais 3 et une fois que je
fais en plus E4 et ben je contrôle cette
case là avec ce pion là et cette case là
avec celui-là et du coup le roi noir pas
le roi blanc qui pourra plus repasser
pour aller manger l'autre pion donc au
final ces pions là de défendre
mutuellement malgré le trou qu'il est au
milieu malgré le fait que les pions
seront pas connectés donc s'appelle pion
électrique mais ça aide vraiment qu'en
finale de roi ici il y a encore plein de
pièces c'est pas du tout le cas donc là
je suis pas sûr que cette
pion en un an dans cette position
donc invalid F4 c'est un coup
intéressant ça empêche 3
et ça empêche pour H3 faut prendre F4 et
j'ai jamais vraiment possible à cause de
plus tard le pion B2 qui risque d'être
très faible par exemple si je prends
large prend là si je mange là je pense
qu'ici au noir c'est bien parce que la
Tour Blanche est bonne d'être sortie et
mon pur en plus il revient vers l'aile
pour se reconnecter avec les pions
et si je prends tout simplement ici ben
je prends là je me lasse enfilade plein
de choses et ici les Noirs se sentent
bien
donc
je suis pas sûr qu'il va réussir à la
gagner de l'argent
alors quand même
bien égal
et je suis pas sûr que vous êtes heureux
va réussir à gagner avec les Blancs
d'ailleurs j'y crois pas trop trop pour
vous dire la vérité je vais regarder une
finale des loosers entre 2000 à David et
à lire les infos là
pour H3 donc il veut bien sûr il veut il
veut te recevra il veut ton rêve 3 il
veut essayer d'activer la tour
si je fais tomber tu auras B3
probablement
B3 C4 c'est pour ça qu'ici C4 est aussi
un coup malin qui empêchait le pion
d'avancer et c'est un peu comme tour ici
et aussi tourbé 8 et je prends là bon de
plus
donc tomber 8 B3 roi F7 tours C3 donc
j'ai pas trop peur de partir si je
prends là tu prends là
faire attention imaginons par exemple si
je fais un peu d'attente
c'est un peu agréable quand même à
défendre pour baisser de obliger
on va ici pour prendre c'est ce qui fait
il fait ton A5
et la Tour Blanche elle est quand même
assez active à l'attaque le pion à 7
donc là qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
avec les noix est-ce qu'on vient
défendre passivement
ce point ici sachant que si je tombais 7
j'ai peur que les Blancs réussissent à
monter le roi jusqu'en F3 et à la
grignoter le pion F4 sachant que le roi
noir est coupé ce serait ça pourrait
être difficile en pratique
généralement dans beaucoup de finale on
peut sacrifier un pion pour l'activité
et ici voilà F3 c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui a été joué c'est ce que je pensais
d'ailleurs parce que maintenant manger
là mais je vais peut-être aller manger
ce petit pion avec toi je suis pasteur
d'y arriver mais j'ai l'impression que
je peux je peux récupérer un petit pion
et plus tard me mettre derrière le pion
pour leur passer de la dame
on va voir en tout cas les gammes plus
pour les blancs
même si la finale
bonne chance qu'elle soit nul c'est les
blancs qui ont
et donc
c'est pas sûr que ça gagne un roi F6
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
3g2 alors je peux pas faire ça parce
qu'il va manger voilà bien sûr il faut
garder la tour ici pour couper le roi
blanc de monter
et le noir qui va probablement aller par
là
tour à 4
on va aussi couper
le rat noir
là vous poussez j'ai 5 h 5 alors plus il
y a de pions est changé plus les noirs
on est chance de faire annuler ça c'est
clair maintenant c'est pas forcément au
noir pousser les pions tu sais que
généralement on peut aussi rester comme
ça avec le roi tranquillement et
attendre
parce que par exemple sur un comme j'ai
5 ici ben il y aurait tour échec et puis
ça a perdu avec le pion et la tour je
pourrais te manger donc des risques un
petit peu pris
et le fait de le G5 et 20 H5 pardon ça
peut alors là je pense que ça va je
pense que c'est ça a l'air d'être assez
tranquille mais faire attention de pas
trop pousser des pions inutilement parce
qu'après des pions il bouge plus
et je peux me faire manger au fur et à
mesure donc faire attention ne pas trop
trop bouger les pions quand c'est pas
nécessaire
moi j'aime bien ça empêche un peu H5 ça
prévoit un petit peu les différentes
[Musique]
possibilités mais mais voilà j'ai pas
fait G5
peut-être que c'était le bon goût
mais je trouve que
je trouve que c'était quand même assez
assez grande belle c'est pas à te
prendre des risques c'est au blanc
maintenant de montrer qu'ils peuvent
gagner
donc les blancs essayent de passer et
salut à toi mon gré j'espère que tu vas
bien tu passes une un bon samedi
un bon samedi après midi samedi soir
donc tour B4 donc là il faut attendre
avec les noirs
pour essayer de
monter ici
tout rinceau en fait vous voyez que les
blancs de plus mais j'ai du mal je peux
pas avancer le pion à cause de la tour
qui va manger pas bouger la tour à cause
du pion qui sera perdu
je pousse mon roi bah oui tu peux et un
jour je pourrais aussi attaquer les
pions
et c'est pour essence cette équipe et
très grande chance de nul quand même
maintenant on voit que
il met la pression il y a un pion de
plus et puis aussi mais autant vous
voyez qu'il a quand même 6 minutes
d'avance et avec deux minutes à la
pendule on peut se tromper la finale
elle est je pense à d'autres tenable par
les Noirs mec peu de temps la pendule on
n'est jamais sûr on peut toujours un peu
se tromper on peut toujours commettre
des erreurs donc avoir un petit peu
ramener le roi blanc vers le pion a
c'est une bonne idée ou pas ça va être
un moment donné ce qui va essayer de
faire mais le problème c'est que comment
tu fais
comment tu ramènes le roi parce que
quand tu passes là je peux te la manger
peut-être ça ça F4 mais comme la F4 et
ben tu vas plus 4 donc imaginons tu fais
ça je sais pas là
ouais c'est pas évident d'aller vraiment
avec le roi là-bas parce qu'il y a deux
pions qui peuvent tomber il y a plein de
cas après plus tard où je peux aller
manger les deux pions blancs
pousser mes pions pousser mes pions
noirs avec le roi et à la fin ça fait un
tour sur le petit pion a et faire mes
dames avec mes pions donc
faire attention ne pas trop trop pousser
non plus
mais je pense justement cette position
d'être nulle
il va déjà être lessivé à deux quand il
va jouer
ouais mais regarde en fait pour
l'instant
Abdou il a perdu la rendre
ça c'est la rampe de et tu sais chez les
perdants il y a que deux parties
ce qui veut dire que
c'est la dernière partie du match
peut-être si Abdou gagne avec les Blancs
il y aura normal les dents mais si gagne
pas la partie c'est perdu ça sera avec
donc la vie qui risque de gagner quand
même enfin de qualifier contre les
raisins donc lessiver oui mais après il
ajoute que antibium 1h30 donc ça va
encore ça va
il y a un peu la pression
du match où il y a une photographe c'est
vrai que
il se sentirait peut-être un peu plus
fatigué
car il Raisa mais bon et elle joue le
rendu du coup contre le gagnant
de ce match
par contre
le caractère si jamais c'est lui qui
gagne et ben il jouera demain
le match demain concarne et en plus la
finale elle est à 19h demain donc ne
venez pas à 17h il y aura personne mais
à 19h par contre il y aura il y aura
la finale
le gagnant qui joue contre contre le
sort et qui voudrait Magnus mais
toujours toute la nuit c'est pas
possible
donc non demain c'est la finale
c'est très évident mais pourquoi tu ne
fais pas
tu peux le faire c'est pas un mauvais
coup en fait moi je vais attendre
finale ben
ça me laisse peut-être le moment la
possibilité de pouvoir mettre mon roi en
H5 H4 et la tour demandera plus le
pionche à cause depuis un f mais en fait
il y a plein d'essais possible pour les
blancs mais pour essayer de gagner la
partie il faut faire des concessions
h ou de le Pione ou les deux ou voilà
mais tu peux pas monter le roi
tu peux pas monter le roi avec le pion
sans rien perdre c'est pas possible donc
voilà la finale qui donne normalement
nul mais tu peux faire F4 hein c'est pas
mauvais cours mais juste pour gagner
c'est
c'est difficile
très très dur
ben en fait il est là il attend et il
pense que c'est nul
et il a bien raison parce que moi je
pense que c'est mieux aussi
c'est le but de la battre Magnus de
cette pour gagner ouais c'est important
et le deuxième ça va essayer de gagner
aussi
et du coup comme on voyait dans le chat
streamlabs c'est le modo bottes comme la
finale qui aura lieu à Toronto
je crois que c'est du je peux les
attaques exact en tête je crois que
c'est du
9 au 16 je crois un truc comme ça 9 au
16 décembre
il faut tenter quelque chose donc là il
y a eu il a réussi à jouer les 5 avec
les Noirs c'est cool ça lui laisse ça la
possibilité
maintenant il faut essayer de jouer même
G4
et en fait maintenant il va attendre
avec son roi il va venir ici il va
attendre et c'est très très dur de
pousser ce pion à parce que ce pion il
est impuissable tant que la tournoi
reste derrière donc une idée pour les
blancs
n'importe où quelque part pour férir la
tour et si jamais le roi je perds le
pion et si je perds le pion et ben j'ai
aussi un pion qui qui avance moi donc en
fait dans tous les cas les blancs soient
ils arrivent enfin soit il donne le pion
à F pour pousser le purin il est noir
pourront au talent toujours sacrifié
leur tour sur l'option
soit je sais pas
tu vois il faut jouer avec les mains il
y a un coup à faire quand même
et par exemple c'est un coup comme tout
Rin peut-être ici roi F5 qui pourrait un
tout petit peu poser problème et des
réseaux un petit peu et moi j'ai 6
empêche pas F5
et chaque fois
bien sûr rouage 5 est-ce qu'on joue pour
B4 le retour donc on répète
que je peux ramener mon roi moi je vais
manger le pion
ouais
moi je vais faire ça en fait
ça à manger
ça m'a l'air nul à
assez facilement en fait je vois pas
trop comment il peut se passer avec les
langues
j'ai pas de truc salut
non il y a zéroduit
hyper alors c'est cool parce que j'avais
j'avais dit avant le début du match que
était le
gros favori de la pompette enfin de du
match et là il s'est quand même bien
fait avoir dans la première partie à
David qui a fait une partie
extraordinaire
le mec est en réunion et qui vient nous
voir quand même salut garius
tour + 3 vs roi ça peut mettre ou ses
pattes ah non ça gagne ça gagne tour + 3
c'est surtout à ce niveau-là ça c'est ma
terre
tour + 3 ça gagnait contre roi
ça gagne les yeux fermés
c'est une grosse surprise
[Musique]
mais pas tant que ça la Zaventem qui a
sorti saut
laservic qui fait un beau tournoi et qui
est capable on le voit encore
méritant donc oui c'est une surprise
mais pas non plus
c'est pas non plus improbable
on voit plus d'hommes saga
évidemment que ça gagne ma glouche
d'encre a été joué
pour tout rajouter attention au matin
un joli petit matou donc ça a été évité
bien évidemment à la croix H4 et là le
pion qui va qui va tomber il a 17 ans la
zavik il est pas français il est
il est
[Musique]
il est bien le russe il me semble
F4
[Musique]
G4
on va commencer à pousser à pousser les
pions on pousse je pense qu'il faut
mettre le roi en G3 en fait
alors pourquoi battle orange
parce qu'en fait voilà quand le pion il
arrive en imaginons si je joue mal
le pion l'arrivée
alors que si mon roi il est couvert par
un pion comme ici et ben sinon ça j'ai
pas échec puis dames si je bouge la tour
il y a pas d'échec donc je mange le pion
et comme mon roi il est couvert on
appelle ça
parapluie c'est un thème qu'on appelle
le parapluie le fait de se cacher avec
des pièces adverses et donc là la tour
bouge plus parce que si elle bouge et
ben je prends le pion et il y a pas
d'échec pour le faire et donc moi c'est
une contente tranquillement sans que lui
puisse rien faire quoi donc ce pion en
fait il va être perdu la tour va devoir
bouger et je dois en manger et pas bon
j'ai RIP mais je mange normalement ce
que je voulais faire et après échec et
puis voilà ça fera nul quand même
donc croisez 3 a été joué
si vous regardez la sortie SCOM j'ai
l'évaluation en direct de la partie en
termes de pourcentage c'est assez élevé
franchement
à votre avis qu'est-ce que vous pensez
du du pourcentage des deux joueurs pour
l'instant après 660 de coups quel est le
pourcentage de bons coups
des deux joueurs alors un indice ils ont
exactement la même score déjà
à votre avis pourcentage il est de
combien
97 9k
par un seul en Provence
pas vu la partie 39
90 il y a 63 coups actuellement 98 396
99 97
il y en a un qui est il y a un qui est
bon
apparemment ce que vous avez dit
mais
mon clavier 110
92 92 sur Youtube Alban Riom
et on a 99,6
c'est un truc de fou
et c'est nul rien à faire donc ça a fait
nul comme on l'avait dit regarde il a
fini par ramener madame là et il a fini
par mettre il peut perdre le pion mais
bon bah
que je fais avec les Blancs
qui pousse je fais dames sacrifie mais
après il pousse et je sacrifie aussi
donc
ils ont fait avec les Blancs c'était off
il a fait 99,6% de précision tandis que
la zavit il a fait 99,7 sur 71 coups ça
calme un petit peu gamin franchement ils
ont joué stock fish gros stockfish et
deux joueurs qui ont qui ont hyper bien
donc déjà de base de base
la partie bon c'était une position qui
était théorique jusqu'à très loin donc
c'est c'est leur préparation maison qui
qui ont joué tout seul et après ils ont
juste très bien joué la finale la finale
franchement bon c'est pas pour non plus
mais c'est pas très très dur de trouver
les cours B3 dans cette 3 c'est assez
facile de trouver les coûts de côté
ici bon là on voit F3 le bon coup quand
je vais l'ordinateur c'est le deuxième
coup F3 c'est pas le premier mais en
fait ça reste toujours dans les un ou
deux premiers coups et les coûts sont
assez faciles donc
voilà on essaie c'est quand même
impressionnant de voir à la fin la
partie où ils sont dit que ils ont fait
une performance
assez élevé en tout cas
non je pense pas qu'on retourne en vrai
pas du tout salut
la finale ça va être bah là dans
quelques instants je pense
on va avoir enfin bref je vais regarder
là je vais vous mettre à jour les
caméras je vais voir si
elle est déjà là ça va commencer je
pense faire un petit break peut-être 10
minutes pour pour l'azalik qui vient de
se qualifier pour la finale et ça a
commencé en quelques instants
[Musique]
le score il a un petit
Magnus la 115,9 il y a pas de épinglé
non non je n'ai pas mis donc tu peux
vous la question peut-être que je Magnus
je te dirai demain
demain 19h d'ailleurs demain c'est 19h
que ça joue c'est pas à 17h alors je
vais moi de mon côté faire une page de
pub parce que vous savez il faut que de
1 il faut que je prépare la scène avec
la caméra de Magnus et en plus Manu ce
qui est pas encore là en plus je vois là
je viens d'ouvrir
d'ouvrir mon truc mon livre il est pas
encore connecté donc je dois préparer
tout ça
et donc je vous dis à tout de suite
dans 5 10 minutes dès que je vois ma
news arrivé je
reviens et donc ça sera pour la regarder
pour la finale du bracket des loosers ma
firouzja contre lasalik d'ailleurs je
suis bête c'est pas c'est pas qu'un
scène que j'attends c'est c'est à lire
ça
il est il est pas connecté non plus donc
je dois attendre les raisins
et dès que dès qu'il arrive et ben je
reviens très vite sur le stream et
ouais ouais c'est lui et pas et pas ma
puce je me suis trompé et donc dès que
ça arrive je reviens 5-10 minutes pas
plus et je vous dis à tout de suite
[Musique]
et le sud de retour ça commence à
l'instant et voir son prêt
[Musique]
et ça joue le 4 je suis vraiment arrivé
puis il attend
pour cette première partie
avec ces trois
donc très classique pour l'instant
petit rock
alors petit
qui joue quoi
ou d'ailleurs je fais n'importe quoi je
viens de voir que je vous ai pas mis les
bons les bons les bonnes caméras je suis
désolé
je ne vois que j'ai terminé bonne caméra
je vais vous changer ça dessus
ouais c'est en fait
j'ai absolument tout inversé
alors
je sais pas du tout fait attention je
suis désolé
voilà c'est mieux comme ça
c'est un peu mieux comme ça je crois
mais désolé je
non il a pas 14 ans il a 17 ans et il
est très proche de Dali présent en âge
il faut que je change sur l'autre c'est
de 5 noir et du coup je me suis trompé
dans les deux scènes bien évidemment
quand on se trompe on se trompe toujours
bien
c'est pas drôle
hop là
je voulais te faire un truc
c'est bon
donc il y a des blancs dans cette partie
et le score c'est bien 0-0 j'ai pas mis
désolé j'ai fait ma pause j'ai
complètement oublié de remettre le score
hop on est bon et en plus on est en
finale on en finale et pas en
demi-finale je vais tout changer
à plat
ok là on est vraiment bon en plus vous
pouvez même voir même voir le le
rings de ma muscuration pendant qu'il
est pas là chez lui la qualité de l'air
elle est ok
alors malheureusement j'ai pas les
boîtiers d'autres joueurs que Magnus car
Wana
et un autre joueur je sais plus qui est
avant de Forest
mais j'ai pas du tout
les autres donc je peux pas vous dire
comment il fait chez Ali raisin comment
il fait je sais pas David je peux pas
vous le dire ça c'est
impossible de savoir
alors du coup alors je vais revenir un
petit peu sur la partie donc
classique
avec des 5 jeux parallèle noir un coup
très actif qui laisse du coup la cible
en E5 pour pour les blancs H3
fou H5
et ici cavaler les deux à la ici
logique je peux beaucoup de légumes
comme Laurent
non je crois que j'ai pas la réforme
avec la blague de
[Musique]
Laurent
je la connais pas celle-là
17 ans ouais il a 17 ans
lasalika les tout jeune
donc A5 c'est un coup qui permet
d'empêcher un peu B5
contrôler un petit peu fixer un peu la
structure et souvent on voit dans ses
parties souvent un pion insiste qui peut
être un problème il y a une partie un
peu un peu comme ça à la Coupe du monde
entre
carvana et pas structure un peu
similaire des fois il est plus raciste
qui avait été en danger par toute la
partie
ok ok
ce weekend
ça t'évitera de faire
mute par Yuma
et le mec qui aime ça il aime il aime
supprimer les messages des gens humains
c'est quelqu'un de très vilain très
vilain très méchant
alors donc à 5 a été joué c'est un coup
assez logique qui permet de bloquer un
petit peu les dames des Noirs vous voyez
sur B5 la présentation donc c'est un peu
gênant
à 6 qui pourrait tomber derrière en plus
donc à 5 ça prend de l'espace ça empêche
B5 éventuellement aussi des cartes qui
pourraient être plus tard un coup
utilisé
alors donc là 13 minutes contre 12 30
x 7 pour les noirs
et l'idée pour éviter le bkract tempo
oui alors souvent ce coup faut à 7 c'est
un coup qui est beaucoup joué dans les
États-Unis pour éviter les coupes B4 ou
des quatre avec tempo souvent même des 4
plus 4 quand même avec tempo mais ici
des quatre c'est pas trop une menace
parce que après puis on prend puis on
prend cavalier prend vous allez voir que
je peux pas en manger parce que je suis
cloué
OK et B4 faut voir si vraiment c'est un
coup qu'on veut jouer alors B4 c'est un
coup vraiment que on peut champion de
position mais la plat aussi d'autres sur
lequel on ne veut pas le jouer pourquoi
parce que si jamais vraiment sur le long
terme les blancs va jouer des 4 et ben
après B4 si vous voulez et ben j'aurais
du mal à le jeu parce que sur T4 mais
sinon j'ai fait ça quand je fais des
quatre par trip on prend puis on prend
c'est plutôt B4 sera en prise vous voyez
parce que le pion stop pas défendre à la
fois le pion B et le pion des donc quand
chez B4 tu sais que tu n'auras pas D4
c'est un peu ça la règle
mais avoir d'encourage vite jouer après
une longue réflexion on croit je suis
quand on s'enlève du vis-à-vis du Fou et
on prépare éventuellement
regarde pour baisser un coup oui oui non
mais c'est clair ça peut être B5 pour
justement affaiblir un petit peu tout ça
à voir
mais généralement les plans aiment bien
garder cette chaîne de pion comme ça
taper sur le 5 par exemple cavalier 4
qui arrive faut bouge qui avait G3 fous
bouge et taper champion de 5
généralement on joue quand même plus sur
le centre sur l'aile mais après ça
dépend F5
salut Cyril c'est le même mais avec Demi
c'est 100 000
je suis désolé c'était blues mais je
crois que là David t'a volé la vedette
il est phrase avec sortir
c'est pas rien quand même
est-ce que je peux juste MP3
j'aime pas trop mettre la lame loin de
mon roi surtout après E5 F5 vous voyez
cavalière qui peut arriver ça me fait
peur cette position
attention attention
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est je trouve que c'est
je trouve que c'est c'est très dangereux
en tout cas ça me fait peur je dis pas
que ça gagne mais en tout cas ça me fait
peur des quatre
il y a peut-être E4 aussi mais je pense
que je peux manger aussi en fait combien
de pièces se déforme de 4 une
sur le cavalier qu'on me parle
donc des quatre moi je suis une deux
trois fois dessus toi tu es une seule
fois donc tu vas pas ma pion aussi
après avoir
ouais je comprends mais mes cavaliers un
coup malin alors je sais pas si on veut
le faire
S4 par exemple ça empêche ça
mais maintenant tu as fait F4
plus revenir
c'est un jeu de manœuvre est-ce que
c'est possible je sais pas c'est ça
reste une option en tout cas sur
canaille là maintenant j'ai aussi encore
le cas qui font encore surveiller
pendant que le clouage il y a plus qu'à
aller qui va manger là c'est c'est chaud
en tout cas moi j'aime bien l'italienne
pour les blancs
pardon
mais j'aime pas laisser le centre au
noir de manière générale c'est un truc
qui me m'a toujours un peu posé problème
parce qu'ici la position elle est pas
évidente à jouer
pour lui
c'est pas quoi faire avec les blanches
il faut se dire je pense que c'est même
pas si grave parce qu'en fait au final
tu vois que le pion le 5 bah lui aussi
il est attaqué deux fois et défendu une
seule fois dans les cavaliers c'est 6
bien sûr je peux pas manger maintenant
parce que je suis cloué mais si jamais
par exemple B3
peut-être que je peux attaquer cavalier
tu bouges je prends le 5 c'est un peu
chaud en fait avoir joué F5 tu es sûr
que lui va te faire
mais après
[Musique]
c'est offensif quoi donc
mp3 c'est quoi le coup voilà jauge il
n'aime pas ça
la jauge elle aime pas ça
alors qu'elle a un coup assez aussi
ah oui en fait
il s'en foutent
le but c'est
le but c'est de mater brick cavalf 4
c'est un c'est un coup qui
[Musique]
qui est chaud tout le temps
des quatre plus cavaliers B3
[Musique]
fougoux
je sais pas trop où je vais je
peut-être que c'est possible en tout cas
tu vois que la chose elle a pas branché
alors que tout à l'heure
tout ce qu'on propose sa branche
avoir
c'est pas c'est pas très malin ça perd
un ça perd une tour
en tout cas les raisins qui prend bien
son temps
il réfléchit beaucoup je sais bien elle
Nino Vevey
[Musique]
alors des quatre quatre c'est pas sûr
parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que des 4 4
ça a l'air logique avec le avec le
clouage mais j'ai encore mon cavalier
derrière donc quand je prends là tu
prends je prends la ça a l'air d'aller
quand même il y a ça en l'air en plus je
pourrais bouger mon fou je pense que la
position à la gamme très solide pour les
blancs ça va
c'est pour ça que du coup des quatre il
faut manger
il faut manger
c'est la partie salut les on Fabien
Léon de
Bruxelles je crois d'ailleurs
prendre le cavaliste durant c'est vous
savez à quel point j'aime les fous
donc vraiment il faut pas voir ne pas
avoir le choix mais là quand même
je peux faire un peu autre chose tac tac
avaler mes trois c'est la partie
tac le fou fou bouge et maintenant il va
falloir manger
en D4
mais je comprends que c'est pas toujours
une décision qu'on a envie de faire
6 pour bien garder le cavalier ici mais
écoutez j'aime bien les blancs
pardon il y a ce petit problème sur le
pion des 4 il y a aussi des idées de
farfouer vite Dame des 6 pour attaquer
H2 j'ai l'impression quand même que les
noirs sont pas mal du tout dans cette
position
va voir un peu comment ça se
[Musique]
ça se découpille mais attention à les
raisins qui est mal au temps déjà 4000
de moins la pendule plus que 6 minutes
c'est dur pour le français hier il a pas
trop brillé contre Magnus et aujourd'hui
il a pas fait une super ouverture pour
l'instant
j'ai l'impression
Skyblues il joue
il joue
salut zen
[Musique]
donc x 7
il faut manger le pion mange pas le pion
c'est catastrophe mais je mange comment
je pense qu'il doit essayer de voir si
on mange du pion pour garder les pièces
du cavalier
parce qu'il y a aussi ça à regarder ça
ça sent mais prends-la j'aime pas trop
parce qu'il après d'en prendre j'ai
l'impression que la paire de fou on
arrive à prendre un petit avantage à
moins qu'on rouleau
il a emprise
mais j'ai pas envie de donner mon fou il
faut prendre les cinq peut-être bref
c'est chaud mais il faut manger le pion
de 5 le pion des cartes pardon il y a
les raisins qui qui se met mal au temps
déjà lors de la première partie il faut
accélérer un petit peu là
il faut accélérer parce que le Bullet
c'est enfin je veux être moins de temps
c'est vraiment très très dur
donc il faut il faut accélérer là
4,44
ca va aller prendre un
et là on va sûrement voir caballer prend
puis on prend
qui va gagner le match
j'ai envie de parler moi aussi
vous pariez 10
moi j'ai 166 cas en point de chaîne
je peux en mettre
des
points de chaîne
je vais prédire juste pour soit qu'il y
en a un qui a fait volume sur
ensemble bah vas-y je te laisse faire
alors je garde mes points
[Musique]
légère avantage blanc je comprends pas
je mettrai en ta joie ok la position est
compliquée c'est pas si clair
si il joue pas il joue pas quoi mais
j'ai quand même pas une position c'est
dégueu
il y a plein de ressources en pratique
ça a préféré les Noirs parce que
ben moi je suis cloué
même ça par exemple je pourrais même
faire bouger madame du style ça et ça tu
vois c'est pas non plus encore
[Musique]
voilà
363 cas entre 58 en vrai vu la position
je serai quasiment tenté de
parier sur sur la navigation
mais bon
il est pas encore mal il est pas mal
mais juste que je trouve qu'en pratique
c'est pas mal pour les pour les Noirs
c'est plus dur pour les blancs trouver
vraiment un plan j'ai l'impression et il
a mal au temps pas trop inspiré dans
cette partie alias
tour à 3 retour à 3 c'est un coup assez
intéressant à tour qui va venir défendre
le cavalier pour pouvoir bouger la dame
je ne sais où les mettre le Cavaillon E5
qui me plaît bien en tout cas
ça me plaît bien
le match complet redstone
va faire comme d'hab il va arriver à une
position compliquée à la guerre
alors faut deux a été joué
bon 400K contre 200k je pense qu'on peut
faire mieux si vous voulez si vous
voulez parier sur le match
en tout cas
je vois que
vous pariez sérieusement
parce que la zavik il est quand même
encore une fois
il est censé être
paravori mais
il y a quand même 200 cas dessus et tout
à l'heure il a battu Abdou quoi donc
c'est
un bon joueur
[Musique]
salut Manu
300K
[Musique]
je te laisse le faire
pas
non je parle pas je parle pas
donc il veut se décloter
il faut prendre tout reproche j'imagine
pour les 5 dans l'air aussi
un cas effectivement
je te remercie
je te remercie on va vite
vite changer ça avant que avant qu'on le
voit dans le
dans le chat
je te remercie
on a rien vu je vais même regarder je
vais même supprimer ton message hop
personne n'a rien vu personne n'a rien
vu voilà
personne n'a rien vu
allez l'après midi va se terminer 310k
contre 588
et du coup du coup c'est moi qui devrait
enlever la prédiction tout à l'heure
donc tout en 4 avec les jeux on défend
le pion en des quatre
ah oui je sais d'où il est je sais d'où
il est
c'est le principal
le reste son prénom son nom de famille
c'est un peu moins important
à retour des 8 en fait les Noirs ont un
jeu tellement plus facile c'est pour ça
que je disais que que le noir était pas
si mal mais après sur long terme si
j'arrive à activer mes fous
je suis pas mal avec les Blancs quand
même
mais
en dessin qui fait vraiment un gros job
et le fouet a du mal à vraiment sortir
peut-être dame pour cette défense ici
défendre là
et c'est compliqué Fiero qui a 3 minutes
à la pendule 3 minutes contre 6 6 20
c'est la grosse bataille ici
alors il y a pas encore
ça peut être un coup attention au
tactique sont tactique je pense que faut
prendre des quatre doit être un coup
ici avec d'un point là bien sûr son
dernier F7 peut-être que là peut-être
que la gâteau 5 effectivement à ce
moment là oui je sais pas si on s'est
bien compris nightmare
mais je peux pas faire quand je veux
mais
je pourrais faire tout ça
et retour à 5 tours
et alors
et alors Cyril je comprends pas
je prends
madame défense
et il faut prendre des quatre directs
alors du coup il donne le pion pour
manger
il donne une PS4 pour manger
pourquoi pas
alors si je prends des sets
comment ça se passe c'est quoi les
bailles
parce que je tourne B8 aussi pour manger
B2
mais tiens c'est pas mon copain
mais si je prends des huit après il y a
assez salaire je suis pas sûr et ça
marche très très
[Musique]
manger F2 fois et en plus qui me laisse
de manger la tour avec une découverte en
F2 oh ça va hyper fort ça comment je
défends
[Musique]
comment je défends dans
un point 4
incroyable
je crois que ceux qui ont parié pour
laser
en train de se frotter les doigts
de fou et puis on a 6 ça reste quand
même contre jeu mais les noirs sont
pleines quand même clairement mieux ici
c'est toujours prendre des quatre
coins des cadres c'est la partie tournoi
des 4 tout brillant mais c'était un peu
le seul coup aussi j'ai l'impression
oui il aime bien les positions où c'est
où il est à limite foutu il a du jeu il
a un pion et de la part de fou ou il a
un peu le jeu quoi il aime bien les
positions avec du jeu mais là c'est pas
Fiero qui me pose problème c'est à David
qui est en face
extrêmement bien quoi
je mange la part de fou je prends mes
deux je sais pas ce que ça vaut
le B4 là
un jour
différent
qui va tomber si je mange là prise
t'auras là peut-être mais bon j'ai fou
aux trois qui va défendre l'option
je pense que les je pense que les noirs
sont très bien
mais vous trouvez le coup
parce que dans le premier 6 on sent
qu'il y a du jeu quand même chez les
Noirs quand même à moi qu'il faille
manger des 6
et qu'on est cavaler ces deux
un truc comme ça
sur ça peut-être que j'ai travaillé ces
deux tours le fou je mangerai là
et après je pouvais manger ici peut-être
que comme ça il y a des chances de tenir
avec les avec les Noirs mais attention
quand même
bien les blancs
il veut y avoir du jeu
et mais bon moi j'ai quand même une
quête et plus
et je veux essayer d'éviter tout ça pour
dire et fort aussi là c'est au noir de
jouer
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici
quand même être le coup numéro 1
généralement
quand tu as une qualité de plus
généralement tu veux changer les pièces
mais ce pion l'idée c'est la question
c'est vraiment comment
ce pion il est vraiment
prenable
parce que par exemple si je joue pas
faute F4 donc ça va quand même pour moi
je ne guettais plus tu as peur de fou
certes mais bon mais fou ou 3 j'ai
cavalé là
après je prends là je prends là donc là
c'est pire tu as même plus la barre de
feu
du coup ça a l'air quand même pas mal de
manger des 6 je pense que tu as un
champion de prendre tour B8 est fou F4
comme on a dit avant ça a l'air pas mal
du tout parce que la part de faux elle
est vraiment forte
en plus c'est une menace de fouet fuite
la tour
il peut y avoir un match du couloir et
là j'ai pas 36 cases de partout il y a
quand même des problèmes mais je peux
faire ça je peux faire après un foulard
et j'ai vu le jeu également c'est la
part de fou qui joue c'est c'est pas
simple
les fous peuvent être plus forts que
nous tourne dans une position et c'est
pas c'est pas ce Cloud
ça dépend
là avec peu de temps la pendule
peut-être les blancs
mais j'ai du temps peut-être les Noirs
je me dis en fait aussi je défends je
vais gagner quoi
enfin
je peux
[Musique]
réussir à digérer le matériel tout ça
mais avec plus de temps la pendule c'est
vrai que c'est plus simple pour les
blancs je pense
F4 pour moi et le seul coup ici
parce que il est pas
recettes ouais je l'ai vu après tu
prends j'ai ça et ça
ça c'est aussi un plan intéressant
ok ben écoute c'est chaud c'est pas si
clair
c'est pas si clair trop G8
trash 4 H6
qui a l'air pas mal
mais sur H4 par exemple 6 Kratos
et sur roi là bon je sais pas si je
mange là je pense pas que je le mange là
mais je mets la pression un peu sur les
pions même après voilà le pion ici peut
être perdu sur échec
il y a des idées un peu mais H4 ça m'a
pas mal
[Musique]
et là je pense que je vais manger F5
quoi qu'il arrive
ce pion qui peut aussi tomber mais
écoutez je commence à bien nommer les
blancs en fait
après tout
je trouve que c'est pour noir parce
qu'il y a des menaces de partout même si
j'arrive un jour à faufler mon fou ici
ben il peut y avoir des trucs là-haut
des menaces problèmes sur le 7
avec peu de temps attendu
j'ai l'impression que la personne est
les raisins est quand même bien plus
facile à jouer
quel dessin
cavalier dessin de jouets alors à ce
qu'on mange ici si je mange là
maintenant il y aura ton reflet
parce qu'il y a plus le tout à l'heure
donc est-ce que tu as envie changer les
tours auprès du pion
je pense pas
à moins que tu fasses ça ça
[Musique]
qui est arrivé qui a réussi à retourner
un petit peu la bonne vision on a
l'impression qu'il était pas très bien
mais au final
merci hyper chaud
donc on connaît pas le raisin de la
partie
allez reviens s'asseoir peut-être en
fait c'est la lumière
pour ceux qui a fini la partie
ça fait nul après
proposition nulle d'allier
[Musique]
ça m'a l'air faire parce que il y a fou
de pions pour la pour la tour le roi
blanc il est ok
et limite les blancs sont un peu mieux
ici
alors les prédits c'était sur le sur le
match ce week et pas sur la partie
donc là il va avoir la deuxième partie
qui va enchaîner d'ici quelques minutes
et
[Musique]
cette fois-ci c'est la zavik qui va
avoir les blancs donc peut-être pour la
dernière partie
de la journée donc je vous rappelle que
ça se joue en deux parties et en cas
d'égalité il y aura un magasin donc ça
fait mieux la première si ils refont nul
il y aura une partie Armageddon avec
enchères par contre si un des joueurs
gagne la partie il se qualifié pour la
grande finale face à Magnus Carcen je
vais vous montrer un petit peu le
bracket final regardez on a une baguette
de gauche enfin en haut à gauche qui est
arrivé jusqu'à droite avec Magnus qui a
gagné tous ces matchs et qui est dans la
grande finale et ensuite tous les
joueurs qui sont dans le raquette du
dessous c'est les joueurs qui ont déjà
perdu
une partie et en fait
ils ont perdu un match mais ils sont
encore vivants seul match en fait donc
on a ici Furious juin qui a
gagné tous ces matchs après bien sûr la
défaitement
du premier tour et revenus maintenant il
a battu tamatabeille il a battu saut il
a battu a besoin et maintenant il joue
contre allez raisins donc le vainqueur
de ce match affrontera demain à 19h
Magnus Carcel
car scène qui a gagné il y a 3-0 contre
Heroes gens car tiennent extrêmement
impressionnant dans ces parties donc un
match palpitant en tout cas à suivre et
donc on va peut-être connaître après la
prochaine partie
le futur adversaire de
deux cartes scène pour 7 finale parce
que
ce sera soit la dernière soit la
dernière ça va dépendre vraiment
[Musique]
de
du score de l'Armageddon ou pas alors je
veux changer de scène du réserves à
prendre les Noirs dans la prochaine
partie
et le score ça va être
ça
c'est bo2 pour la poule des perdants et
aussi pour les divisions de et 3 par
contre pour la poule des gagnants dans
la division 1 et 20 c'est bio4 donc
demain ça sera en bo4 best of for
le Magnus contre le gagnant de ce match
et éventuellement il y aura même deux
best of for ça va dépendre de si le
joueur
qui va gagner ce match
pas Magnus ou pas parce que je vous
rappelle que pour être éliminé il faut
perdre deux matchs pour l'instant ma
venue ça part du Zéro match donc
imaginons siali Raisa gagne ce match et
ben il va jouer contre carcène et comme
un Iran déjà parlé un match hyper son
premier match contre manus et ben il
sera éliminé par contre si pas Magnus et
ben tous les deux ont perdu un match
donc il y aura encore un match de 4
parties et du coup pour gagner le
tournoi et Ben Ali résa il va devoir
gagner
ce masque et après il va falloir qu'il
gagne deux matchs différents contre
Magnus donc beaucoup beaucoup à faire
alors que les autres joueurs ils ont
tous une seule vie donc voilà
avoir
voir
toujours pas toujours écoutez moi je
vais faire une pause 3 minutes faut que
j'aille hydrater et je reviens dans 3
minutes je vous mets une petite pub et
j'arrive tout de suite ne bougez pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai de retour et la partie qui va
recommencer d'ici quelques instants donc
il y a eu match nul dans cette première
partie de match de finale de la poule
des perdants donc cette poule qui va
d'ailleurs qualifier pour la poule des
gagnants ensuite on va avoir un match
entre Carlsen contre le gagnant de ce
match là donc il y a deux parties pour
l'instant c'est la première il y a ma
tenue et la deuxième qui va commencer
dans un instant avec éventuellement
d'armage et donc si les joueurs refondu
quand la partie qui vient tout juste
de commencer salut
donc E4
ou pas alors tout à l'heure il a le D4
contre un contrats
C4 tranquille
donc là je pense qu'il va rejouer pareil
avec des quatre
en tout cas ça m'a l'air
salut Cécile
il y a une nul ouais
les deux sont jeunes en plus
alors
je vais commencer à jouer ils ont
commencé mais c'est vous savez que nous
on a une minute de décalage donc dans
très peu de temps ça a été 4 on savait
que c'était des quatre en cinq jours qui
jouait qui a joué ça tout à l'heure
contre contre
standard tout ça
cavalier prend
tous les doigts
parce que c'est important de me donner
ouais en fait
R6 si tu veux c'est
un des sponsors de l'événement donc ça
sort de boîtier qui permet de de
mesurer l'air la qualité de l'air chez
nous et donc du coup ça les sponsors
donc les joueurs disposent d'un boîtier
chez eux etc et malheureusement
moi j'ai accès que au boîtier de Magnus
de Caravana et de vente forest qui joue
même pas le tournoi
donc bon bah soit j'enlève soit je
laisse niveau ça remplit un peu l'écran
mais en vrai
on s'en fout un peu mais demain pour le
coup pas demain à 19h malgré
donc
ce sera au moins déjà plus normal
si le sponsor qui vient d'avant comme
sort qui qui
veut qu'on fasse ça donc il y a pas de
souci
d'ailleurs Laurent il a un boîtier aussi
il a un boîtier
il a un boîtier R6 Laurent
moi j'en ai pas j'étais oublié moi j'ai
été oublié
en fait Laurent il l'a eu je pense à
l'époque où il travaillait avec James 24
il y avait des il avait droit un peu à
tout avoir
mais c'est normal que moi j'en ai pas
et donc c'est la partie
donc ici les Blancs ont la perte de fou
mais en contrepartie qui a des problèmes
sur quasiment
ici Laurent c'est pas trop à ce qui va
aller avec le pion H4 là qui est en
prise
il y a eu grand rock il a pas essayé de
défendre ce pion
c'est que sur un coup comme G3 on aurait
peut-être pu voir peut-être pu voir le
coup de 5 ici
avec le vis-à-vis sur les tours ça
aurait pu être un problème atmatique oui
j'ai 5 h 5 peut-être encore une fois
j'ai 6 on sait pas trop ce que je coupe
à l'espion mais on sait pas si ce client
est bon ou pas bon
et de jouer
et
les blancs s'en foutent un petit peu du
pion ils se disent bah si tu manges
alors qu'est-ce que je fais si tu manges
d'ailleurs je dois avoir au moins
peut-être tout rachat qui m'a l'air pas
mal qui permet de clouer le fou c'est
que tu bouges le bail à une il y a un
clouage et sur tout rachat je me dis
peut-être qu'après j'ai trois au four ou
un coup qui pourra attaquer le fou pour
essayer de faire ça là-haut
ça m'a l'air intéressant j'ai au moins
ça après peut-être aussi des réactions
sur la colonne C avec une prise en
dessin qu'un jour ou pas mais en tout
cas il a pas mangé du tout quand il a
joué à 4 et en fait sacrifiant sur
cavaler prend un cadre j'imagine que les
Noirs veulent jouer le coup peut-être
des 5
ou peut-être je dame B6
alors B5 là pour pas perdre de matériel
je dois faire [__]
sinon je perds on est d'accord et après
la prise je mange du pion
si je dirais pour faire la colonne
et quand cavalier
ca va et ces trois grammes B4 je chasse
puis tu reprends à deux
et même si je prends pas le pion ben les
problèmes sont quand même ouvertes sur
le roi c'est intéressant
donc cavaler prend un 4 c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui veut à lireza il se dit bah
vas-y franchement
j'ouvre la position sur ton roi et je te
masse
j'aime bien la position dans des raisins
je me dis que dans une partie en rapide
comme ça c'est vraiment son style de
balancer un peu et ça a l'air ça a l'air
intéressant comme
[Musique]
comme
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer avec les
Blancs alors
B5 je pense ça va être le prochain coup
d'Alco et c'est vraiment de cavaler des
cartes d'abord peut-être au moins
essayer de chasser des pièces et de
jouer sa position de recopposée
à trois semaines pas l'air d'être un
coup général parce qu'en fait bon
c'est joué et en plus c'est le bon goût
alors je disais ça parce que c'est
généralement dans ces positions des fois
on n'aime pas trop ce genre de coupe à
cause la case B3 qui peut être un jour
contrôler
mais pour l'instant je vois pas comment
je peux arriver avec un cavalier en
béton c'est aussi la bonne raison je
peux pas mettre du café
j'ai pas de cases pour y arriver
pour arriver ici
même pour arriver à 5 c'est pas facile
donc du coup c'est pour ça que A3 ça
empêche qu'elle va les bécartes ça
empêche à trois donc c'est un coin
intéressant si les Noirs n'arrivent pas
à mettre leur cavalier ou leur pièce sur
la case B3 et comme j'arrive pas à le
faire c'est un coup il était intéressant
maintenant ce que je vois là je vois B5
et je vois éventuellement plus tard un
coup B4 qui peut arriver et vraiment
ouvrir la potion du roi blanc donc ça
fait un peu peur il faut calculer il
faut être sûr de soi que par exemple si
on fait 5 x 2 B4
là j'ai plein de trucs derrière bon là
je vois qu'elle descend tout en bas mais
B4 est un coup
et surtout on prend qu'elle va les
prendre ça fait peur tout ça ça fait
peur
donc on a envie de le faire
des trois peut-être parce que manger en
dessin que c'est pas un bon choix je
mange des pions qui va s'ouvrir ici ça a
difficile pour les blancs mais par
exemple on s'en foutent des trois je
pense que j'ai quand même encore une
fois ce D4 ce malheur assez embêtant
je sais pas à quel point c'est fort B4
mais vous voyez contre un genre comme
comme ça j'ai pas trop envie d'ouvrir
mon roi quoi
si je prends un catch au minimum et le
roi souvent et si je prends la cavalier
prendre peut-être je peux manger en
dessin
donc là j'ai plusieurs coupes possible
j'ai aussi B3 qui a un coup
ça peut même prise en A3 et peut-être un
coup aussi ce qui est rigolo parce que
je me masse à deux
c'est marrant à 3 la jauge elle aime pas
du tout j'en étais sûr
et pourquoi tu aimes pas
il est fou l'ordinateur
[Musique]
et je perds madame donc j'ai perdu mais
ok
[Musique]
ça perd direct apparemment
et si je mange du pion en fait il va
juste manger là et là il a dit que pas
rien
victorien champion de plus avec tes
blancs mais bon j'ai peur quand même
hein les tortues qui arrivent mais on
voit bien j'ai dû à trois
les Noirs ont quand même du jeu mine de
rien donc il faut être sûr de soi quand
on joue c'est pas des questions parce
que
tu manges un pion certes mais ton roi il
est tout ouvert donc
on va vraiment comment est-ce qu'il joue
cette position aldresa
[Musique]
on s'en fout c'est pas du tout pour tu
vois si je prends H4 on a déjà parlé
parce que je prends un H4
et ben j'ai des idées comme ça et en
fait c'est moi qui vais attaquer avec
les lampes à pas du tout du genre à
prendre un pion pour après être comme ça
et pas bouger c'est l'inverse c'est un
peu comme un VL en fait elle veut donner
matériel pour s'activer et attaquer quoi
donc il va pas manger un pion pour après
se dire bon maintenant que moi je fais
du coup il fera pas ça il va plutôt
faire B5 B4 donner le pion
2006 3 avril je crois je sais pas en
quelle année l'année oui
en décembre
alors cavalid 17 a été joué par lire qui
va garder des cinq pour plus tard
il est impressionné de voir toutes les
médailles qu'il a gagné
on veut on veut tout ouvrir avec les
noirs
E4 ça a commencé à être un coup c'est
plus possible
mais là je fais quoi je vais où
d'ailleurs
je sais pas trop où je vais
regarder les dessins
c'est vraiment difficile à eux se
positionne
parce que le roi étant est encé un la
tour la dame est de j'ai vraiment envie
de
avec les noirs de tout ouvrir un tour C8
par exemple
B5 C5 du coup 4 ça clairement
son intérêt ici
la chose elle n'aime pas trop mais à
chaque fois que je joue un coup de la
jauge
et me suis pas
comment je B5 je veux regarder quand
même mais je crois pas trop je pense que
ça ça
va pas le faire un tour pour le noir il
y a pas l'attaque la colonne B mais j'en
fais rien de la colonne B après je vais
manger un pion même là c'est pas mal
hein
donc quand tu peux pas jouer ça
pour le cavaler mais cavaliers
je suis pas fan de son petit coup
cavalier BD7
je voulais bien aimé faire ça avant
qu'il fasse le 4
pour gagner un peu l'initiative avec P4
derrière mais bon je suis d'accord qu'on
va pas attaquer
le roi blanc alors que j'ai rien sorti
quoi je suis bien d'accord mais ça donne
envie de faire des cartes quand même ça
donne envie
ok d'ailleurs l'ordinateur il vient pas
du tout
alors qu'est-ce qu'on joue sur E4 il
faut brûler la cavalier donc là on a
trois cases possibles
et je sais pas laquelle est la meilleure
pensée 3 mais du coup prend mon four
revis mon fou défend le roi te sourire
après des cinq
ça me gêne
c'est pas si
il y a aussi c'est cette effectivement
ça garde la pièce ça garde les 5
mais tu sens que c'est pas la case où on
veut le cavalier quand même
mon père pas mal de temps quand même
avec les noirs
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de se cavaler du
coup
prendre ces trois c'est plus safe
ben moi j'aime pas trop prendre ces
trois parce que je vois vous prendre je
vois la tour qui s'ouvre le fou qui
s'ouvre le roi qui est plus défendu
qu'avant Laurent
et je trouve que la position elle est
extrêmement facile à faire pour les
blancs extrêmement sale solide c'est moi
qui le centre c'est moi qui ai les
ruptures avec des cinq
je trouve que les blancs sont trop trop
bien quoi et là le cavalier aussi c'est
un canard pour garder les pièces
ce que je trouve ça enfin je trouve bien
maintenant il faut balancer des cinq V4
il faut essayer de faut essayer
d'attaquer parce que vous voyez là dans
la position
en fait les blancs l'avantage
des du centre de l'espace de la part de
fou
ça fait déjà beaucoup du roi même
peut-être même je dirais parce que le
roi finalement
dans cette position
[Musique]
et à force d'avoir plein de petits
avantages tu vas finir par avoir un très
très gros avantage
je crois que c'est la scare qui disait
ça
x 2
x 2 ça empêche
B5
jouable bien sûr
même petit rock on n'a pas trop envie de
le faire parce qu'on se dit bah j'ai
quatre H5
les blancs sont vachement en avance dans
l'attaque quand même
donc le roi même pas envie de le roquet
on a même pas envie ouais c'est dur
j'aime pas du tout la position de
[Musique]
trouver une solution
à avoir un Magnus contre la zavent en
finale
j'aurais pas parlé dessus quand même
il m'avait demandé en début de
tournois de donner mon
pronostic sur la finale de l'événement
j'aurais jamais dit en Magnus oui
jamais mis en finale
c'est un genre très bon très talentueux
mais il est quand même moins fort que la
majorité des joueurs de plateaux et
c'est un énorme énorme énorme
perf que nous fait ici la vie que dans
ce tournoi
moi le trouve pas suspect du tout notre
cas il a fait ses preuves
maintes reprises et il joue hyper bien
il fait des bonnes parties
un peu avec toutes les
toutes les
mesures en tutrice tout ça
je pense il a 2600
donc c'est un jeune en forme qui
progresse et qui promet aussi
j'aime beaucoup ce joueur
ouais 25% mais il est jeune
il a joué moi je me posais la question
quand je voulais enfin je l'avais joué
d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises moi-même
sur les tournois sur tescom donc je
l'avais joué en
Tuesday je l'avais joué en Arena Kings
plein de fois et j'ai toujours perdu et
bon je viendrai
mais il m'a toujours explosé je l'ai vu
après enfin j'avais plus de 3000 3000
3100 francescom quand même pas mal
et après du coup je l'ai vu
au championnat du monde de glitch c'est
rapide et donc en réel du coup
et je me suis dit tiens ça va être sympa
de le suivre parce que comme moi je l'ai
vu plein de fois sur Internet briller et
être hyper fort et ben on va voir ce
qu'il donne en vrai parce que bah
écoutez il y a plein de joueurs qui sont
très bons sur internet mais qui est en
live sont moins fort et il a fait une
perf au Blitz et rapide à plus de 27 50
il a battu beaucoup de joueurs du Top 10
enfin c'est comment ça s'est preuve dans
le Blitz et rapides IRL du championnat
du monde
donc
ce qu'il fait en sur internet il a
refait en live donc bon
moi je te dis pour moi il y a aucun
doute
d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un un peu
éventuellement nous retrouver la le test
championnat du monde je sais pas si
quelqu'un dans le chat est capable de le
retrouver le classement des thérapie des
championnats du monde ça peut être
marrant de pouvoir vérifier un petit peu
ce que je dis mais de mémoire il avait
été il avait été d'ailleurs dans les il
avait le premier rôle jusqu'à un certain
moment je crois qu'il a très bien fini
dans les deux tournois où là il y en a
au moins un qui a très bien fini mais
genre c'est le souvenir qu'il a vraiment
brillé très tournois donc pour moi c'est
pas vraiment
une surprise
on prend A3
la chose elle aime pas ce que je dis
mais moi je moi j'aime bien ce que je
dis
je me dis que c'est chaud mais la chose
je n'aime pas ce que je dis hein
c'est le seul coup
et donc là plus ou moins réussies qui
voulait faire et il a ouvert un Laura
blanc mais attention que le roi noir il
est aussi
[Musique]
il est aussi sous les foudres
de la paire de foules blanches
et
c'est chaud
c'est chaud il faut trouver un abri à ce
roi
là je n'aime pas elle aime pas ce qu'on
dit
si un magasin je cherche rien un peu
voir si je peux trouver le plus result
é maintenant un Pilos
tout d'abord là je pense
c'est ma news qui a tout gagné
et là j'ai
non c'est le rapide
parce que ça c'est bon ou pas
j'ai pris deux liens
pas sûr d'avoir les résultats ici
mais avoir un petit résultat ça peut
être pas mal
je sais pas si quelqu'un dans notre chat
non je crois que j'ai pas et je vais pas
chercher ça pendant le live parce que du
coup on va pas trouver si quelqu'un les
a vous nous dites mais sinon tant pis
sinon tant pis
16e Blitz
mais
ok mais est-ce que tu as un lien
pour qu'on puisse un petit peu regarder
ce qu'il a fait comme un résultat mais
16e
enfin je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte mais
c'est quand même quelque chose quoi
[Musique]
malheureusement il n'est pas modo sur la
chaîne
courage 5 un coup
pour faire quoi avec toi
tours
il est tu m'as dit
ça c'est quoi ça que tu m'as envoyé
rapide et rapide il était
42 en rapide
ok rapide il a fait quoi
donc il a fait nul en 2600 2016 nul
Savannah nulsation
2016 perdu André Kim nul 2007 nul 2006
battu 2005 battu 2006 50 est perdu en
2006 donc là c'est un bon tournoi mais
c'est pas non plus incroyable
par contre j'ai pas le lien
des Blitz est-ce que tu as le lien des
Blitz aussi c'est une bague
c'est plus impressionnant
[Musique]
du Blitz merci beaucoup
alors on va voir ce qui fait un blitz il
a fait combien tu m'as dit 16e alors là
il a battu trois 2006 d'affilée puis ma
média Rohff donc on commence à 4 sur 4
quand même hyper 2008 il bah ça doit ni
hyper guéri il va chez paris-nov il va
cadrix il perd un Martin violent c'est
un jeune un jeune joueur d'Arménie
hyper André kiné
et il fait nul
matelasuke en 2005 Salem pétrole ok la
page de 47 il n'a pas joué beaucoup de
monde mais il a quand même fait un Super
Sport et 16e au championnat du monde de
Blitz c'est quand même sacrément
sacrément costaud quoi
alors on va revenir un peu au stream
parce que là j'étais vraiment dans les
résultats mais c'est vraiment un super
joueur en tout cas il y a aucun problème
là-dessus quoi alors juste il a mangé le
pion ça on avait vu tout Revin et
j'avais des questions dans le chat
regarde après sur
les raisins à l'air il est pas il est
pas en confiance tu vois je suis un
fallait jouer quoi toi
c'est difficile
il n'y a pas que dire ok il a juste pas
envie de roquet
ouais il faut jouer en tout cas il va
falloir se sortir de de ce clouage
dame 2
et maintenant il faut que je revois
parce que alors là il faut sortir du il
faut absolument sortir du couteau à Agen
c'est obligatoire je joue pas
mal se passer déjà là c'est dur mais
oui il y a toujours des menaces de B4
puis on prend il faut prendre les quatre
ou même à 3 qui peut arriver aussi
et franchement
franchement c'est chaud hein
pour pour aller raisin contre 32
3 B1 on s'enlève du vis-à-vis
très bien B4 ça reste encore un coup
qu'on a envie de jouer mais P4 fous
prends des cartes peut-être
d'ailleurs dans sa marche
pas où ça marche je pensais même ajouter
mais je suis un peu fou je crois
un truc comme ça et dire que mater en
fait
maté quoi
je pensais même un truc comme ça
mais en fait ici il va manger à y manger
ici bref c'est un peu compliqué mais
mais il y a plein de tactiques de
partout là je vois bien et donc la B4
dame prend le 7 est une idée mais j'ai
aussi même pour mes quatre qu'elle a pas
mal
à trois je sais pas je pense qu'il y a
pas assez de menaces pour les Noirs
tes pièces sont pas du tout
pas du tout bien placé tu as pas
l'attaque avec les Noirs parce que tu as
pas la tour en jeu tu as pas réussi à
donc
[Musique]
il sort la tour et maintenant peut-être
que B4 avec la tour qui va pouvoir
rentrer en jeu pour être plus efficace
[Musique]
prends un trois marches il faut prendre
à trois je n'ai pas vu du tout
prends à 3
là je n'aime pas
et moi j'en pense quoi peut-être je
prends là non
je prends tu prends je prends et je
défends tout
ça a l'air d'aller tour H5 c'était autre
chose et autant H4 en tout cas c'est une
faute selon la jauge et c'est un blitz
il y a 52 secondes pour le noir contre
deux minutes 40 attention à les raisins
qui ne peut pas perdre cette partie si
il perd la partie c'est terminé ce sera
ça sera
perdu élimination du genre français
faut pas qu'il perde
donc tout rage 4
comment est-ce qu'on continue avec les
Blancs
il vient de sortir
encore une fois à livraison et
tranquille c'est normal
c'est absolument normal
c'est ce qu'il est en train de faire
dur dans les 3 ans contre Magnus ouais
bon après tu peux le refaire tu peux
revenir encore mais
les raisins il a pas aujourd'hui c'était
pas la qualité partie était pas géniale
pour la connu être bien meilleure que ça
en fait donc fou à deux a été joué
ça fouette en prise on va jouer solide
et là il faut que je vais vite
il faut que je vais vite aller réserves
P4 encore une fois ça marche toujours
pas hein
faut prendre S6 c'est le problème par
contre si je joue B4 c'est la partie B4
prise vous prend et essayer de essayer
de [__] la merde
obligé
de rentrer là-dedans
P4
je dois manger je sais pas trop
manger fous prends je pense même tout
reprend peut être un coup d'effort parce
que ça tourne à l'état en mauvaise ici
qu'on a envie de faire un truc mais il
faut prendre le jus
s'il y a pas de tactique derrière
il faut manger
il a fait de la B7 pourquoi dans
7 secondes
c'est perdu parce qu'après ça échec d'un
point il y aura échec et d'un point F7
donc je rate tout donc a été joué pour
manger comme ça de la tour et anticiper
le tour C1 de tout à l'heure
après un incrément il y a trois secondes
par coup donc il y a plus de temps à la
pendule 17 secondes mais quand même
trois secondes par coup c'est pas encore
terminé vous savez qu'elle est
raisonnable c'est un joueur qui est
extrêmement fort extrêmement rapide donc
c'est pas si grave d'être mal au temps
comme ça
pour un joueur comme lui il panique pas
normalement il arrive encore à bien
jouer et la zavik qui descend aussi
autant 38 secondes
et tout machin a été joué
mais il faut trouver quelque chose il
faut trouver un coup pour prendre
attention à toi poser problème
maintenant
est-ce que tu auras fait c'est pas un
coup pour essayer de défendre B4 et
ramener la tour par 4 ah pardon
je fatigue moi aussi
heureusement que je joue par là j'aurais
été content de faire ton H4
qui est B5 a été joué libère ce petit
pion
dans B6
comment est-ce qu'on termine dame 5 fois
[Musique]
il était aussi
mais la finale quand même elle est pas
terrible je pense pour pour les noirs
qui va tomber en plus à B3 voilà je
pense même manger mais attention que
manger quand même ça offre des chances
de nulles adversaire
[Musique]
absolument
mais ça m'a l'air très très dur mais
j'ai 6 je vais avoir tout à 7 pour
attaquer FC
ouais le temps c'est pas clair encore il
y a plus beaucoup de temps ce pion à
trois qui est toujours un peu embêtant
s'il arrive à sortir le cavalier ça peut
être maggulante quoi
c'est pas comment il sort le cavalier
mais si jamais il arrive à sortir
allez faut la gagner là
[Musique]
et le cavalier
apparemment roi et fuite faute il y a
plus de temps je peux pas trop trop
expliquer pourquoi l'ordinateur dit que
c'est pas bon
on va rester sur le direct cavalier 6
et le cavalex qui commence un petit peu
à s'activer au fur et à mesure
car il y a 5 5 ou pas
il y a toujours le tour là et j'ai pas
la fourchette ici
fousser 5 il y a plus de temps la
pendule 10 secondes contre
pas grand chose
allez il faut jouer il faut jouer il
faut jouer il faut jouer 4
allez 3 secondes par contre on récupère
vite c'est bon F2 qui peut être
intéressant attention au pion F2
moi je le sens bien
voilà jauge la chose qui est descendu
regardez F5 on mange tous les pions
incroyable il Raisa incroyable il va
gagner cette partie il va la gagner
du cavalier
tu as fini encore c'est pas fini cette
partie quand beaucoup à faire si tu
prends prends je gagne deux pions qui
avancent très très vite j'ai 3 G2
attention est-ce que ça rétables
j'ai deux géants
est-ce que ça
c'est noir oui hein après les gens ont
10 secondes donc c'est extrêmement chaud
pièce de plus pour aller raisin
je pense que l'apparition elle est
complètement terminée mais on va quand
même laisser aller à terminer à cette
partie
alors on met le fou ici on bloque
et on va tranquillement aller manger et
puis on va F4
bouge le cavalier peut-être il y a aussi
ses pions sur casse blanche enfin
attention au fou qui pourrait venir là
c'est qu'elle venait à partir aussi
je prends là il y a fou et huit hein
attention quand il fait le tour avec son
roi je crois
fais le tour
qui est
comment est-ce qu'on passe
quelque part bah oui il était pas très
bien mais bon après
mais attends que là il a il a attention
hein
je pense qu'on va assister on va
assister à fou cavalier contre roi avoir
un peu la belle technique d'Ali resa
pour mater avec cavalier fou
parce que dans le doute il va essayer de
sacrifier
[Musique]
la seule chance cette position elle est
perdue donc il est obligé d'essayer de
simplifier
F3 il faut prendre
ça va se terminer comme ça
ça va se terminer cavalier fou pour
mater mais bon c'est assez facile au
niveau de cavalier fou
non ça va mater facile ça mater très
facile pour aller raisin
ça va pas il y a pas de suspense
pas de suspense
le roi pendant le bon coin vous savez
que cavalier fou et ben il faut voilà ça
c'est la finale et ben il faut mettre le
roi dans le coin inverse du Fou donc là
j'en fous de quasiment il faut que
dans le coin du fou il faut que j'amène
le roi là ou là le roi blanc
est dans la dans la couleur inverse donc
c'est bien il y est
donc là vous allez voir est-ce que il
arrive à mater en 50 coups
on voit les rataquiller par ci donc soit
il a fait pâte et qu'il est parti tilter
soit il a gagné
et là voilà ça c'est la position
gagnante le W du cavalier par PAF
c'est le cavalier ça c'est assez facile
cavalue ici voilà et le fou qui vient
ici
hier j'ai fait une vidéo du matin car il
est fou je l'ai fait la vidéo
je n'ai pas encore publié mais elle est
prête
elle est prête sur ma chaîne elle va
être bientôt très bien tôt
on remonte le roi fouet
c'est facile pour moi alors c'est facile
pour moi c'est très très facile pour les
raisins
et s'abandon parce que là ça va être mat
en quelques coups alors comment matte
ici j'attends voilà échec voilà et maths
donc il avait vraiment le temps écoutez
elle qui a gagné le match mais qui est
venu de très très très loin dans cette
partie il était pas bien du tout et il a
réussi franchement à bien leur tourner
dans la phase de Bullet notamment ici
avec cette qualité de moins qu'il avait
et le pion le coup G3 apparemment
c'était une gaffe terrible de la part de
la David qui laisse vraiment des chances
à adversaire à la place je tourne
et s'activer plutôt de défendre le pion
G3 comme ça et après le pion a été
finalement perdu donc après ça fait
partie du jeu c'est comme ça que ça
marche et
du coup
il a gagné sa partie donc rapidement le
bracket regardez ce qu'il devient alors
on a aliénation Rosa qui a gagné le
bracket déperdant et qui va maintenant
s'opposer une nouvelle fois à ma news
Carcassonne donc demain à partir de 19h
on aura le match la grande finale entre
15 scène et Ali redafiros 20 ils sont
déjà joué en finale de la poule des
gagnants donc c'est mal passé pour Ali
raisin je pense qu'il va vouloir faire
beaucoup mieux lors de la poule enfin
lors de la grande grande finale donc
demain à partir de 19h on va connaître
ensemble le dénouement de de cette
de la compétition donc je vous dis
vraiment merci à tous pour avoir suivi
le stream on va partir avec un petit
raid
chez le frère
de Ali raisin
et oui il stream en ce moment et je
pense qu'il estime d'ailleurs la partie
de son frère donc je vous envoie chez
son frère et je vous dis à très très
bientôt donc demain 19h et juste après
ça je vous fais la prédit promis donc
bonne soirée à vous à bientôt et passez
un excellent samedi soir ciao ciao
j'ai envoyé le raid qui appartient dans
quelques secondes
ouais 7 6 donc bonne soirée à tous à
bientôt et portez-vous bien